new league documents show some really
weird weird grand proposals
where uh the in wuhan
there was uh a few groups associated
with this project you may be familiar
with um eco health alliance they wanted
to like aerosolize some kind of vaccine
by spraying bats i mean i i got to be
very careful because it's a a weird
grant proposal for some kind of
aerosolized vaccine in 2018 and they
also wanted to do gain of function
research on bet corona viruses
specifically to make them more
infectious
and there are leaked documents now
coming out the telegraph published this
and they were seeking funding from
darpa
what does darpa stand for jack as you do
that's the uh defense and
defense advanced research and
development agency all right i was like
i don't know i don't know the so that
that is the to put it this way it's the
pentagon's r d department um it's also i
think famous for um essentially what the
the early stages of the creation of the
internet um
yeah
darpa i guess they had a defense in
front of it yeah right so anyway darpa's
denying that like we did not provide any
funding for this well yeah it does look
like they didn't right but do it they
were trying and we also have this uh it
may not be the biggest story in the
world i think a lot of people might hype
this one up a bit more is a ccp defector
who said he warned us actually this is
big he warned u.s intelligence agencies
in november of 2019 that china had
released some kind of virus at the world
military games in wuhan
and they ignored him uh september it was
september september yeah no he's he the
games are in september he warned them in
november oh okay you in november he said
hey you know those games that just
happened i was people got sick right
okay so two months later so apparently
he has contacts still within china who
have been giving him information could
you imagine if the trump administration
had been like that is very important we
should look into that well the question
is who did he reach which agency did you
reach out right and apparently i guess
the individual he reached out to didn't
follow through and they were like i
thought he should be talking to the
people directly and then they kind of
ignored it because you know they didn't
hey man my inbox is full and what they
knew now yeah so we got we got a lot to
talk about but obviously we're hanging
out with jacksonville ladies and
gentlemen welcome aboard tonight's
edition of tim cast iron yeah
i like it what do you do who are you my
name is jack
former navy intelligence officer yes i
know right um and the host of human
events daily shooting up the charts on
on on your podcast platform of choice um
so we just launched that with uh with
turning point kind of like giving us a
nice boost we're part of turning point
live there and also just put out a new
book a new kids book called there's no
such thing as free ice cream
i i have to disagree with you i was at
occupy wall street when ben and jerry
showed up and gave out free ice cream
was it really free
or did you have to
raise your communist festivals raise
your fists no that's racist game give
over a piece of your soul
they were just giving it out to
everybody with smiles on their faces
the ice cream is free but that's what
gesture requires of course you had to go
to
occupy wall street exactly so what they
were really buying was a presence that
occupied to push their political causes
but that and that's that's so the book
actually like
um you know and we're doing it with
brave books so we're not even we're not
even doing amazon for with it by the way
it's bravebooks.us no amazon no
canceling you know all that stuff and
it's it's a series so it's like ashley
sinclair is involved elizabeth johnson
so there's like a gender book there's
like a pro-life book the gender book is
called elephants aren't birds which is
true by the way in youtube just so you
know elephants are not birds um
and i can perfectly see the animals on
this list here they are they're
absolutely mammals yeah they're not
avians and they don't have a lot of hair
but they do have hair they do so um
without those elephants take two years
to gestate really is that true it's a
long time that's a while it's gonna be
uncomfortable i gotta
well actually we have an article about
your book we'll we'll bring it up oh
yeah we'll do we'll do the pitch later
but but hey what's up good to be back
it's been a little been a minute i think
uh you know we uh we're doing like the
poster wednesdays for a little bit and
um yeah i don't know what happened but
well i was on the road actually i think
that's what it was yeah yeah you went to
alaska too that was cool alaska was
awesome we'll talk about that too we got
we got ian yes we do and elephant
gestation anywhere between 620 and 680
days almost two years yeah
a long time to be in a belly yeah like
wow
ian is still just dating right now
what's up everybody good to see you jack
ian is actually uh spiritually just
eating i'm a huge star wars fan as you
are i'm i'm really excited you're here
talking about the force a little bit
okay yeah before the show we were
talking about how ryan johnson did an
amazing job by destroying the star wars
franchise this is an interesting theory
and i would like to subscribe to your
newsletter okay we got uh lydia pressing
the button i am pushing buttons in the
corner i'm wearing my glasses today this
always gets comments they're for blue
light they're not actually prescription
guys i passed sour patch kids in
followers we did so yes when did this
happen right last night yeah so what are
the numbers show me the numbers is it
neck and neck i have 97 and they have
like 96.3 oh my gosh yes
do they even know defeated we gotta have
them on the show we need folks we need
to meme them
away with this thing we need to we need
the sour patch lids memes crushing yes
or i guess squishing right yeah right
squishy
before we get into everything my friends
we got an awesome sponsor the sponsors
that you know and love we have biotrust
keto elevate mct oil powder just go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com and you can
secure your supply of keto elevate up to
51
off and they say right there in big bold
letters yes the keto diet works wonders
for increasing ketone levels inside your
body in turn supporting boosted
metabolism elevated energy and enhanced
mental focus and i got to tell you
incidentally i have been doing the keto
diet lots of heavy fats and i love
putting this stuff in my morning coffee
with some uh uh with you just just
basically that maybe some heavy cream if
i'm feeling it but this stuff's really
really delicious and i got to tell you
um
i'm not like doing a strict diet or
anything i'm just basically trying to
avoid all the processed sugars cutting
down on gluten and carbs and stuff cause
i felt like doing it i've been using the
keto uh elevate stuff i feel like a
million bucks no no joke i feel better
than ever so now i'm like the better i
feel the more i'm like get that sugar
away from me you villains and ian's been
screaming in my ears about sugar being
bad thank you for listening
a week and a half ago i went keto for a
week and i started waking up at 7 30 in
the morning no matter what time i go to
bed i'd get up with the sun and then
over the weekend i ate some bread and it
tasted like paper like at first i was
like oh this isn't really even food and
then after three or four pieces it
started i started to get addicted to it
again the bread so i'm back on keto i
haven't touched it in three days and
you've been up in the i've seen ian
awake in the morning which is
we're actually scared it's incredible
people were running like is is he in
awake don't be don't be a sugar burner
folks don't be a sugar burner be a fat
burning machine that's right and you can
get your c8 mct oil powder at e eat
write and feel well dot com you get a 60
day money back guarantee
you get
enhanced energy levels healthy appetite
management
increased enhanced mental clarity and
focus which i always that's the one line
i'm not supposed to mess it up i'm
supposed to enhance mental clarity
bullseye keto elevate is very gentle on
your stomach you get five grams of the
highly sought after mctc8 free shipping
on every order and for every order today
biotrust donates a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid hungry.org to
date biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids please help
them hit their goal of 6 million meals
this year plus you get free vip live
health and fitness coaching from
biotrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
free new e-report the top 14 ketogenic
foods with every order and again go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com support the
sponsors that are willing to be on shows
like this because it's the opposite of
cancelled culture it is
what's the opposite of cancer promotion
culture promotion culture i like it
there you go they're helping make shows
like this possible and so we have
tremendous respect it's a it's a it's
not a boycott it's a bike hot a bicon
that's right and you can also go to
timcast.com stole that from charlie
clark yes there you go go to guys.com
become a member we're gonna have a
members only segment coming up around
110 pm and we've actually we're about to
overhaul our members section
which we're going to be adding new shows
those will be members only content from
the vlog we've got a new show called the
green room which is when guests arrive
early and they talk about nonsense you
know maybe there's a guest and you never
heard about their famous cookie recipe
and we were talking about eating
chickens earlier we were talking about
eating chickens um and there were some
top secret phone calls see all that
stuff's fun i think that's i don't know
that's top secret anymore not anymore
not anymore the project veritas i think
i think that's out actually but yeah
they did give us kind of a little bit of
a tip off because they knew we were
going live tonight that's right and so
we'll uh midway through the show we'll
pull the project veritas stuff because
they've got some big revelations yeah
creepy creepy stuff i'm gonna take a
look right now to see if it yeah it just
dropped all right so we'll pull it up in
a second but don't forget to like this
video right now see the little like
button you gotta tap it and then you
gotta subscribe hit the notification
bell and then you gotta take the url and
you gotta post it on all the other
social media platforms if you really
wanna support the show because there's
no marketing there's no commercials
youtube doesn't prop us up we don't have
billboards we're not in airports
it's just if people like the show
all the growth we've had on the show has
all been organic we've done no paid
promotion we've have no we had no
financial support from like wealthy
individuals or networks it is all
because people actually like this like
this show they've they've helped us by
sharing this video so um that would be
greatly appreciated let's talk about
this first story
and this one is one of the creepiest and
strangest stories
from newsweek darpa denies funding wuhan
institute of virology amid alleged
document leak
they say
newsweek cannot confirm the veracity of
the drastic group or the existence of
the project diffused documents described
the groups as the documents were
provided anonymously
darpa the u.s advanced research projects
agency has denied funding research at
wuhan aduan lab after a re after a group
released documents allegedly detailing a
coronavirus research proposal they say
drastic is a group of activists who say
they are working towards solving the
riddle of the origins of sars kovit ii
and the virus that is behind copen they
say they were given documents by
anonymous source which details something
called project diffuse according to what
appear to be funding proposal excerpts
published by drastic project defuse
aimed to reduce the threat of bat-born
coronaviruses through research and was
headed by peter dashik president of the
president of the u.s rece us-based
research organization ecohealth alliance
it would have run between 2018 and 2022.
drastic states the research proposal
would have involved advanced and
dangerous research and to bet
cronoviruses in cooperation with the
wuwon institute of virology and other
facilities and said the research would
qualify as gain of function a process
can be used to make viruses more
dangerous however jurassic to the
documents show that darpa rejected the
defuse proposal in part because of gain
of function concerns specifically they
said something about we're not you know
we're not so sure about an aerosolized
vaccine the idea apparently was that
they were going to make some kind of air
airborne aerosol that would take various
uh corona coronavirus particles they
would spray bats with so that bats would
develop some kind of immunity to it and
darpa was like that sounds really
dangerous to do i'm with darpa on this
one yeah i'm gonna go ahead and say i
agree with darpa
i'm not a big fan of math let's not go
spraying the vaccines into the batcaves
it makes me think of fluoride in the
water like just dumping the medicine in
the into the medium that we is there in
the water really yeah i've heard not
here oh okay good now we we have well
water better it didn't used to be
yeah not everybody some places uh uh
don't but we have well water so uh plus
we have like a nine stage filter or some
ridiculous number yeah so the article
basically goes on to say like gain a
function is really really bad and all
that stuff they go on to then say in a
statement in newsweek darpa denied
funding any activity associated with
equal health alliance or the wufan
institute of virology a spokes spokesman
said in accordance with the us federal
acquisition regulations we are not at
liberty to divulge who may have or may
not have submitted a proposal in
response to any of the agency's
solicitations further information
contained within bids is considered
proprietary and can only be released by
the bidder that being said darpa has
never funded directly nor indirectly and
as a subcontractor any activity or
researcher associated with eco househol
equal health alliance or the wuhan
institute of virology
why would
peter dashik he's the guy who
spearheaded the lancet article that said
this is not from a lab
and now we hear that uh these documents
who is then later kicked off the team by
the way right and now lance it's like
coming out with a statement we should
investigate because it looks like a lab
leak and a serious and open debate
so this guy who's trying to get funding
from darpa look there's the nih is one
thing with fauci you know being like we
would like to fund research in this area
because you're the national institutes
of health or whatever it's another thing
when you go to darpa
i mean what what could they possibly be
trying to do pitch to darpa hey you want
a weapon
you know it's amazing because you know i
know alex was here on monday but doesn't
this sound like something that you'd
hear on his show right yes
he's like the chinese were working with
a us
firm and they went to darpa with their
documents and said we were going to be
aerosolizing the bat caves and like it
just it just let me like it's like he
needs to be are you going to go for it
he'd be like
you know i'm telling people that
the chinese are coming to darpa because
the u.s is working with china to to
spray the vaccine on the bats and and
i'm just like alex slow down
look they're gonna go they're gonna go
into the cage we're gonna fact check
this one
and then i'm like i really don't think
the chinese went to u.s defense research
projects to get like you know to get
money to do a lab to make gain of
function bio weapons to spray bets and
i'll bet google it and then i'd google
it and be like uh from newsweek uh uh
jamie pulling on yeah
virology was uh and and equal alliance
was seeking money from darpa to
weaponize you're like to weaponize the
aerosolization the human foreign uh
cleavage site of the
okay so this uh says that what alex
checks out we're screaming about is
entirely true so get the jar jamie get
the jar
and you put another coin in this is yeah
you go eco health alliance went to the
darpa is this a chinese this is so what
if when you look at the actual documents
and i've gone through this and i do
actually uh dig through it on we talk
about it on the podcast today as well as
at humanevents.com uh where we go a
little deeper and we actually i was
actually reading the table of contents
on this because i've only been doing the
podcast for like a week but i'm trying
to get canceled as fast as possible
so i started i started reading the
actual table of contents in the leaked
document and i started to go through it
and i'm like i don't know if i can say
this you know and it was getting a
little long and we do we do a shorter
version thing there but they're talking
about uh infectionist experiments using
entire captive bat colonies uh they're
visiting the caves and the one that's
really big the introduction of human
specific cleavage sites so do you
remember when there was that big article
that came out by the former new york
times reporter where he was it was sort
of like the article that changed the
conversation at least for a lot of
people out right all of a sudden he was
like all of a sudden he was like hey we
probably should talk about the lively
because there's some weird things well i
actually went in and read like all seven
thousand words of that because that's
what i do um
and there's a huge section where he said
okay we're going to talk about science
now so for anybody who wants to talk
science this is that section
and one of the main things they were
talking about was this human fern
cleavage site like that's that's where i
heard the phrase was in that article and
so i'm looking it up i'm talking to
people that um that i know who have been
in pharma and r d et cetera and one of
whom i'm sure is listening right now and
um
the thing that was very interesting to
them was they said we don't know how
covet 19 could have evolved this so
specifically because it seems to be the
perfect addition to a corona because
remember so coronaviruses there's not
one coronavirus that's a family name so
that's like a genus that's like a family
of a type of virus and so for covet 19
they're just saying that we haven't seen
a another coronavirus with this specific
um
feature to it right this this specific
function
is a word and you know and that's that's
where gain of function actually comes
from that it doesn't have this function
like gain functions that it no one had
gained this function before not none of
them at least that they'd found and so
the point of it was this made the
spike proteins essentially because you
always heard this early on spike
proteins h2 receptors spike proteins h2
receptors so our lungs human lungs have
these ace2 receptors well what the wuhan
institute of horology was doing was they
were humanizing mice what were they
doing with the mice they were giving
them the ace two receptors in their
lungs and so trying to engineer the
virus so to see if a chimeric virus
could essentially be be able to be
inserted so they become uh
transgenically more
pathologically transmissible they were
enhancing the pathogenicity i had to
practice that one like three times in
the mirror it's a good word
for doing that to work it out and so
it's really interesting that again
you know to everybody out there that's
kind of following this once more and not
to like delve too into it you just see
these same terms coming up again and
again
both at looking at the science of
what is coveted 19 what makes it so
unique what makes it so uniquely
transmissible in humans and then also
these grant proposals that all are
associated with the wuhan institute of
horology
i want to read this from the telegraph
they say darba refused to fund the work
saying quote
it is clear that the proposed project
led by peter dashek could have put local
communities at risk and warned that the
team had not properly considered the
dangers of enhancing the virus gain of
function research
or releasing a vaccine by air
wow
so so darpa was the the voice of reason
here yeah yeah darpa saying hey guys
let's let's just you know you know we're
we're busy
yeah of course yeah he's
so so dashing the original burton the
new one oh no i haven't seen that one
yet well the new one's all prequels
though right
yeah yeah so in the new one you know
what it's about yeah it was caesar and
all yeah yeah so they he he makes a
virus together strong yeah it makes a
virus that enhances the intelligence and
functions of the chimps but then it
turns out that virus kills humans so the
humans start dying off for the most part
and the apes are intelligent building
civilization and i guess that's the
prequel in the future the humans are all
gone and the apes are all smart or
whatever except for james franco but not
anymore because there's no he does die
from the vice i'm pretty sure okay but
there are so many humans who are immune
and there's very few there's like oh the
guy from zero dark 30 is in one of them
so you have you have darpa basically
being like
if you guys do a gain of function virus
and then spray covid particles on these
animals which then travel you know you
might destroy the planet
so consider so we we don't know
according to these documents if they
they where it doesn't say if they're
actually funded it says their proposals
um so maybe they went to fouchy and
found right and so the point the point
that drastic makes and drastic has had a
lot of of legitimate scoops and research
that's come out in they have an
excellent track record when it comes to
this um the point that they make if you
read their summary is that you know
we're not saying we're not trying to pin
this on darpa we're interested in what
type of research and what venues were
they looking at because as darpa said in
that disclosure statement that hey this
is proprietary stuff we're not actually
allowed to share it because of the rules
associated which makes sense right if
you're applying for a grant proposal but
you know if i you know if uh if uh
moderna shares it and you know sends me
a proposal and i share their grant
proposal with jay and jay because i you
know maybe my buddy works at j j and he
said he'd give me some money if i did
obviously you can think of proprietary
issues there but the question is what
avenues of research were they looking
into what was going on and then
did they ever eventually get funding
from nih or by the way did they get just
funding from the ccp for example to fund
these lines of research so again we only
have so far uh insight into what has
been published from the wuhan institute
and we have better insight into what we
funded we being the us government the us
nation but we don't really know there's
a whole black box surrounding that
entire thing and it seems like every
time we get another leak every time we
get more documents every time we dig up
one of these statements that was made
right in real time when you go look at
this i pulled up that
new york times article from 2017 that
says well it looks like uh we're going
to be funding gain of function research
now which could produce more lethal
viruses right
new york times i'm i'm done playing
games look the hunter the laptop store
the hundred bite and laptop story comes
out
and immediately you get people on the
right of course willing to start digging
into it trying to fact check it verify a
lot of the stuff and it was almost
immediately verified in a bunch of ways
notably tony babilinski who is like a
confidant being like yeah these emails
are real and it takes what a year for
the mainstream media to go oh they're
real by the way and then people go oh i
still remember sitting there and it was
um you know uh you know bannon gives us
the hard drive and that was with raheem
and we were just sitting out at morton's
on the terrace and he starts he's like
oh look at this video i'm like god don't
show me that we're in public you know
but i'm like that's
definitely hunter biden no question i'm
not trying to re-hash all of that
because right i see the snow story and
i'm like we knew this right yeah we we
knew the story was bunk we knew russia
gate at a certain point was bunk i was
willing to entertain russia gate and
then eventually i was just like these
people have lost their minds it was
getting crazier and crazier ukraine gate
was completely bunk it's all been bunked
the media's lied about about way too
much but tim here's the thing is i was
going on every single day publicly
during this period so the eight was
essentially eight weeks before the
election and i was i was going i said
jake tapper maggie haberman actually got
into it on twitter with mark cuban a
little bit over this because he actually
responded i said if you guys want to
come and get a copy of this thing i will
let you sit down i will give you full
access to it i'll let you make a copy of
it i'll let you take it off with you you
can send it to like i would like to know
personally as well but i also understand
that we live in this environment where
there's sort of like the independent
media and then there's like the accepted
formal mainstream media right and so i
understand that unless this hard drive
passes through that you know that
barrier that that you know impermeable
most of the time barrier uh into
quote-unquote accepted media channels as
opposed to like podcast independent
media that's not going to happen so i
said guys come on get a copy of it i'm
more than happy i'm just saying i'm i'm
done playing games when it comes to lab
leak we've got so much evidence pointing
in the direction to
research being funded at the wuhan lab
that was specifically working on gain of
function coronaviruses to infect the
lungs and now we have a coronavirus from
wuhan that infects the lungs bro i'm
done i'm not playing these stupid games
anymore the people understand what
happened at the very least it was a lab
leak and at worst
as this guy says let's let's let's pull
up this article and then hold that yeah
it's simple this is from joe.co.uk
chinese whistleblower claims first covet
outbreak was intentional and i can
believe it this is a guy who defected i
think it was like a couple decades ago
1987 he was held in prisons because he
has been fighting for democracy
but apparently he still has individual
he still knows he saw his sources and
they provided him provided him
information that said that in 2019 at
the world military games
china released a virus now that's his
claim
where were the world military games in
september 2019 they were involved in
johann and nine and there were 9 000
athletes many of whom were sick with
some pneumonia-like disease i've had
i've actually had members of that reach
reach out to me afterwards or family
members and say hey you know my you know
i'm not going to say which family member
was but someone i was related to was on
that trip they came back they were sick
we got sick we passed that along we have
no idea what that was and it's been so
long now that we can't you know really
get tested for it so we're not sure what
happened but a lot of people were saying
the symptoms were
very covet-like so i'll say this
i don't know about intentionally i think
when you look at the lab leak evidence
you would be insane not to conclude this
leak from a lab whether it was you know
if it was intentionally done that's
something totally different
but we actually have a director claims
that he went in november or i'm sorry uh
yes in november he went to u.s
intelligence and said
this thing that just happened
this wasn't an intentional release of a
virus the funny thing is
we we have the benefit of hindsight
we can look back at these past couple of
years and be like why didn't they listen
well think about it the world military
games happens
and some people got sick
so what
so you got a bunch of athletes who get
sick and then you don't even notice
because not not that many get sick and
then some guy comes to you and says
people got sick because china
intentionally released a virus they're
going to be like
what are you talking about
the game's going off without a hitch
especially if they use the phrase you
know if they say oh it's a bio weapon
secret chinese project military it just
it kind of fits that sort of thing where
and saying this for someone who's in the
intel community um
you
you get a lot of walk-ins right you get
a lot of walk-ins you get people coming
all the time with this story that story
and because of the iraq wmd scenario
because of that situation anything that
kind of falls into that bucket of uh nbc
not nbc the company but nuclear
biological chemical there's alway
there's always is a little bit of
hesitancy from people in the community
because of that experience to really
jump on one of those things and there's
hesitancy from people that you know your
middle managers etc to pass that on to
the higher ups the generals or the
dazdees or certainly anyone in the white
house give it to the president just
because of that situation because you
don't want to be the next colin powell
then you know et cetera
were they like i'm curious was uh was
uh more negatively impacting asian
people was that wasn't there something
about like
people who had uh some people had more
ace two receptors based on their
heritage yeah i thought it was asian men
no i thought asian men were less likely
oh i don't know i don't remember yeah
you want to you want to google that but
yeah cause i remember seeing something
about um less ace2 receptors based on
you know different parts of the world
and stuff like that so i'd be curious um
i could i could be wrong about this i
don't know do you see anything uh ian
hmm no uh is this here from
e-turbo news that says east asians and
men have more than say white europeans
okay more receptors which means they're
more susceptible to that that's just
according to this i don't know but
that's so unconfirmed so so regardless
of the outcome i think it's interesting
china's accused of the u.s of releasing
this
but
it was a joint chinese china and u.s
research there was joint china u.s
research being done at the one institute
of virology so
i mean i don't i don't know man
this also says that men have more than
women
by nature
so what do you think do you believe this
guy
i don't know i don't know for sure but i
do know just
from an analysis standpoint i could
certainly see a scenario where
someone not necessarily xi jinping but
somebody in china says hey we have this
situation on our hands it looks like
this thing is breaking out why should we
be the only ones who have to take a hit
on this why should we be the only ones
who have to take the economic hit the
supply chain hit the monetary hit
they're going through a monetary
situation right now with evergrand um
yeah breaking out so why not why not
just let it ride the intentional thing
i'm not sure
there's enough evidence of but a lab
leak right a lab leak but
a lab leak that you don't respond to
immediately
right or
look what happened with fukushima you
think like you think you can cover it up
yeah yeah there's like just just just
get rid of it quickly
and you don't have to admit anything but
but you know i guess the challenge is
they didn't shut down travel to one they
allowed outbound travel didn't they they
didn't yeah so it doesn't sound like
they were trying to uh it sounded like
they were like you know what it hit us
it's gonna hit everybody else so when
when chernobyl happened and um one thing
that hbo totally missed in the chernobyl
miniseries i think is quite good but one
thing that and my wife coming from
having been in the soviet union um
always points out that they totally
missed is that if you look at the dates
chernobyl happens in late april
what is may 1st right may 1st is may day
right in the soviet union this is a huge
day of celebration it's parades people
are outside people are you know garlands
of flowers etc etc so all of that
happens in the chernobyl area and across
belarus where
a lot of the winds were blowing it so
this fallout they allowed that to go on
even though they knew the meltdown had
occurred wow
because they didn't want to admit it to
the west yep and i think it was only
because they detected radiation in
sweden or something right that anyone
started to realize what was going on
with chernobyl because people in sweden
started getting sick and people you know
they started detecting things what's
going on hey russia or hey soviet union
do something you like to tell us yeah
right and so what's amazing though is
because we have this situation now where
what's the difference between the u.s
relationship with china than the ccp
versus the u.s relationship in the ussr
there is a monetary financial and a deep
economic relationship between the u.s
and china that the u.s and the soviet
union never had our elites are getting
rich off of this supply chain off of the
exploitation of cheap chinese labor the
uyghurs etc everything else you don't
have that now so you don't have this
huge i mean look at all the movies the
cultural
john cena going out and speaking really
really bad mandarin
[Laughter]
apologizing
um i love how they mock the bite swab
but then these bites were in the u.s get
on their knees for them which is why
they mocked them because they know their
lesser it's crazy isn't it but so so i
mean this is white left by the way right
so this is the situation and then they
because we are and like our elites are
so in bed with them
you don't have that situation like like
moscow do you want to tell us something
beijing do you want to tell us something
i'm sure behind the scenes you know
there's quite a bit but then a lot of
this was kept and peter navarro has a
book coming out i think his book just
hit number three on amazon where he was
talking about having been in the room
with fouchy um because keep in mind
fauci obviously knows about all this
stuff or has the ability to pick up the
phone and say hey did we you know
something going on over wuhan where's
that guy where's that peter guy you know
did he have something going on with with
this does he know what's happening and
you know we talked to what up peter
dashak not not peter navarro and
and navarro says
that moment never happened right you'd
think like if it's a scene in a movie
right you think the scientists would
come in oh my gosh wuhan that's where
the lab is that's where we were doing
the funding what's what's happening and
then like jeff goldblum runs rushes in i
told you
i told you
it would be considered bad writing right
it would be like the scientist runs in
and goes ladies and gentlemen a virus
has broken out in a city with a virus
gain of function research lab and people
watching it go oh come on come on it
doesn't make any sense it's a little bit
more exciting than that obviously
where's the like where's the farming
village
and then like the peasants get sick
that lands in someone's soup gets in the
soup and then it gets to what's in in uh
an outbreak i think it's the the bat you
know and then bite somebody and then
they go to a casino in macau and there's
like some americans there and like but
you know what
if they were making a movie about this
it would literally be like a guy working
in the research you know wearing in the
restaurant wearing the suit and then he
would be like handling a bat and it
would bite his finger exactly yeah
look around and be like nobody saw and
then you go out and wash and be like i
have a stand well one thing that's some
coughing later one one thing that also
one thing also that i think people
should consider is that even though
they always say there's no evidence of
of um
bats being sold at this wet market uh
keep in mind though that the standards
for control over these type of things in
china are just not that big so there are
also economic incentives that hey if
you're somebody that maybe just works
you're a worker there you're a janitor
or something and you see hey there's a
couple of bats it looks like the
experiment's over they won't miss one
they won't miss two or maybe you know
you're selling them off the back of the
truck to a guy and then he goes and
takes him out into the city it doesn't
have to be at the web market just be
some guy he knows and maybe he's been
doing this for a while and has no idea
right yeah so again right there there
are so many permutations you could think
of to create a lab leak theory that all
of which are very valid and if i wanted
to go uh you know if we were trying to
go from like the most plausible scenario
like research was being done and then
there was a lab leak because of you know
incompetence to the most and completely
implausible one i would love to just you
know theorize about xi jinping trying to
gain the ability to control bats and
wield them like some kind of villain
he's doing that but then but then the
bats you know break out of control and
they were trying to use a virus to
control their minds and then i'll hell
break it seems like more of a kim
jong-un thing yeah i could see kim
jong-un being into that
you're saying is navarro was in the room
when fauci learned about it but he
didn't react no no no well basically yes
and so you would expect so navarro
scientists to be like oh my gosh let's
look in but because he didn't react it
was kind of like why didn't he react to
that right so then eventually it becomes
like the political appointees in the
administration and this is what
navarro's book is entirely about and
he's been there's actually calling me
like a minute ago um
that you know he's just he's trying to
tell people the story of what actually
happened to say hey we found out all
this stuff about wuhan
and then we see fouchy's name on it we
see nih and niaid and we said excuse me
are we funding this stuff tony what's
what's going on here man like what's
just you know we're trying to fight this
thing we don't want people to be getting
sick
do you know something that you'd like to
tell us because keep in mind that when
you go back and watch those old videos
of fauci where he's talking about the
need for gain of function research what
does he say he says we need to do this
because if there is a zoonotic spillover
event we need to be prepared for it we
need to have um elements on the shelf or
resources or at least just the knowledge
sounds like total bull crap to be able
to prepare for something so but just go
through on this right so it's like okay
let's take your word
if that's the case
why didn't you have that moment of
saying oh my gosh they were studying
something just like this hold on let me
call up shir jung lee we'll we'll figure
out what the best because you know it's
like you create the disease so you can
create the cure so
why didn't that phone call ever take
place
i remember seeing that video of fact dr
fauci being questioned by rand paul and
he is shaking yeah and that was crazy
people noticed they like zoomed in on
his hand completely and entirely wrong
and then it turns out that
it was all true we got leaked documents
and more and more information keeps
coming out
i don't understand how fauci's not
already under investment yeah he said
they were not funding gain of reason so
look at this
congress look at the first finding of
drastic in these documents the first
finding of it was so keep in mind i
mentioned that um
there was that new york times article
from 2017 that talked about the return
of gain of function funding however this
was 2018. so the question is if gain of
function research has been turned back
on by francis collins who's the director
of the nih he's vouching's boss it's
collins
so why are they going to darpa if it's
been turned on at nih here's the rub
nih instituted something called i
believe it's the pc3
framework by and by in which they were
going to and dr erbright is part of this
at rutgers that you are supposed to
submit it to this group essentially to
get signed off to say is this going to
create a lethal virus is this something
that does constitute dangerous gain of
function so dashak knows that and wuhan
institute knows that and so they just
tweak it enough so they can argue or
what not even
that framework is only under nih so they
say well if we go to these guys we can't
tell them all the stuff we really want
to do but if we go to darpa maybe we can
get some funding and they don't have
that framework but at least
it goes and says common sense we're not
going to do this guys i have a feeling
they were trying to circumvent the
system if you look at the the amount of
data and evidence that's been coming out
implicating fouchy we're just like a
month away from like a video of fauci
holding a phone and like with peter
dashak at the one lab doing a selfie and
he's like hey what's up guys we're doing
gain of function research on back
chronoviruses and we're going to
increase human transits ability and then
he high fives and then that video comes
out and rand paul is like explain this
video that you took you a wrong rand
that was just us in a lab doing
modifications to chimeric viruses that
would make them enter humans more easily
it's not gain of function research so go
back to it right look at what fauci has
done in the past because he had that
huge very public flip-flop on mask
wearing right early on he says don't do
it then later he says i had to say that
at the time because we had to shore up
the mess supply for doctors and for
frontline healthcare workers but now
that that time has passed the supply
chain is working we are going to open it
for everybody else so i had to say it at
the time and it was for the right
reasons that's exactly what he'll do
he'll say i had to say that at the time
but gain a function of course we were
doing gain of function and we had to do
gain well i don't think i'll ever do
that because that would be admitting to
lying to congress which is perjury and
that's that's actually something where
he's got himself in a little bit of a
trap that's why he was shaking and then
just gets a punch miami just say it then
get a pardon by biden yeah biden good
the pardon power of the presidency is a
plenary power which means it's absolute
um it cannot be overturned by it cannot
be overturned by
uh a a proceeding president so like like
trump can't come in and overturn one of
obama's pardons right and interestingly
enough it can't even be over it can't be
overturned by congress but the supreme
court it can't even be overturned by
yourself so if you are president and you
pardon someone that's it they're done
and you can pardon for more than just
what they've been convicted of right so
this is this the idea of a blanket
pardon and that's actually never been
challenged so general uh gerald ford
does this famously for nixon um aft in
the after the events of watergate and he
does this sort of like blanket pardon
blanket amnesty for watergate and
essentially just nobody decided that
congress said find whatever we're not
going to challenge this but it so that
is sort of the leading theory that you
can give someone a blanket pardon but
it's not actually been completely tested
it's just that no one's ever gone down
that road we gotta pull up this project
veritas story
ladies and gentlemen project veritas we
promised we promised it has dropped a
crazy story the latest fda official blow
dart african americans with covet
vaccine is quote where we're going just
shoot everyone calls for a nazi germany
style registry of unvaccinated americans
quote think about it like the jewish
star what
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait tim
you're you're not saying that right no
i'm reading a headline no that's that's
taylor lee fda economist the fda
economist
said
that
yes yes veritas reports they released a
second video of its coveted vaccine
investigation exposing an uh u.s food
and drug administration economist taylor
lee who was recorded calling for forced
coveted vaccinations and a registry for
all of unvaccinated americans
lee said that u.s government policy
would emulate nazi germany when it comes
to the covet vaccine saying quote census
goes door to door if you don't respond
so we have the infrastructure to do it
forced covert vaccinations i mean it'll
cost a ton of money but i think at that
point i think there needs to be a
registry of people who aren't vaccinated
although that's sounding very much like
nazi germany he said uh and so the
let me make sure i'm being clear
his exact quote is so we have the
infrastructure to do it i mean it'll
cost a ton of money and veritas has
inserted the context of the greater
conversation in their quotes he says
that's
although that's sounding very very
germany lee said
nazi germany i mean think about it like
the jewish star for unvaccinated
americans he said so just to be clear
cuz i want to be make sure we you know
cross all the t's and dot all our
lowercase j's he said
although that's sounding very germany
nazi germany and then veritas includes
the context so you understand in that
quote he says so if you put every
anti-vaxxer like sheep into like texas
and you closed off texas from the rest
of the world and you go okay you be you
in texas until we deal with this
pandemic
lee said that due to a large portion of
african-american of the african-american
community being hesitant to take the
coveted vaccine the solution should be
to quote unquote a blow dart on them
wow what yeah i'm going to be i'm going
to be very very careful about how i read
this but here's a quote it says
i think that a lot of the time so
there's also this issue of i remember
reading about how the covid trials they
were having an issue recruiting
african-american people it was because
of a different medication the government
tried to do that was specifically
designed to kill african-americans oh
like a mistrust thing yeah but this
coveted vaccine is safe though
we uh we know that now but like again i
think there is still this big mistrust
and it's like deep rooted the journalist
says yeah i can't blame them lee says i
can't but at the same time like blow
dart that's where we're going
this so so hold on i'm watching it right
now james just texted it to me so i'm
watching here we always we always want
to be i want to make sure everything
we're doing is reasonable and within
context and that's why i'm you know
talking about what's being said uh it's
one guy it's an fda economist an
economist is not somebody who's going to
be showing up and and instituting policy
on the census
however
as much as that would be the immediate
reaction from mainstream media saying an
fda economist is just opining on us
personally right
i say wow the internal culture of the
fda is psychotic exactly and so if if
this is the access we're getting we're
getting we are getting a glimpse
imagine it this way there's a big
building
big old building full of hundreds of
people
and in the second floor on the top are
all the administrators and all the big
wigs
and everyone in there is hanging out
talking they share a culture in the
workplace
and you look through the keyhole and see
a man say these things
you're like what are they doing in that
building yes i understand this guy is
not an administrator who's going to go
around set policy they actually um they
they clink glasses
[Laughter]
i'm watching it now they actually
they they clink
they clink gas glasses they're right i
don't like it or
i will say i don't think
it's not going to happen yeah there's
not going to be door-to-door maybe a
registry like maybe
um people who aren't vaccinated will be
tracked because we're at that point now
where they're already doing vacs
mandates in a bunch of the big cities
but i really do think the united states
the republic will completely collapse
before it gets to that point let me ask
this question um to people out there do
you want government bureaucrats talking
about you like this
talking like government bureaucrats
should never be talking like this about
the american people talking like they
are drunk with power right whether
whether it's behind closed doors whether
it's at a restaurant wherever this is
right this that's the issue here and our
question is it seems like that's what
their attitude is and he's telling us
that's what his attitude is he's someone
that is behind those closed doors it's
obviously a private conversation and so
the question is and i've gone to this
with people who are vaccine hesitant
and
it's you know you talk to them and it's
not like they're there
there's nothing wrong with them there's
nothing different about them in fact
they're saying the same things the joe
biden kamala a lot of mainstream media
was saying throughout 2020 they say oh
rory you know there's you can go to
msnbc
joy reid yeah here's the interesting
thing all of it
joy reid had responded that saying at
the time i didn't trust the cdc under
donald trump now i'm okay with it and my
response to her is ah yes exactly what
you said but for trump supporters that
under the trump cdc they were they were
okay with it and now under biden they
don't trust it that's the exact same
thing you just said
right but it's okay when she says it
because she's joy reid right and so the
issue becomes
you know and this is something i've said
to people that like like
my position is check with your doctor
everyone should have their freedom and
choose just i'm literally approach
always on this but
i'm also not vaccinated because i have
natural immunity because i had like the
real covet i had like the knock you on
your butt like you know couldn't really
it wasn't really on twitter for a while
um i was just you feeling your chest and
your lungs um
a little bit in my chest i mean i woke
up the one morning had shakes like
legitimate shakes and i was looking at
my i took my temperature and it was low
it was super low wow and
uh then i just threw on a bunch of like
sweat like two layers of sweatpants two
layers of sweatshirts got back under the
covers and then and then my temperature
shot up yeah and went out and it was
crazy and then so that was the first day
there's the pretty much the only day i
had that level of temperature but
you know i just kind of hung out and
they eat like like vietnamese foe and
it's incredible
in my castle we do not ban that's right
it's not it put it i'll put it this way
i'll put it this way it comes with the
cilantro dude yes oh this laundry right
right yeah um egg rolls i'm a good
leader so i am making sure that my share
of the cilantro goes out to all thank
you beloveds thank you pepper jack let
them eat cilantro
yeah i'm like like it wasn't the flu but
it was like not fun i wouldn't want to
do it again so i have natural immunity
we've had a bunch of people on who and
this is really amazing because like even
alex mentioned how like covid was scary
like you wake up one day and also you're
like you're out of breath constantly and
you can't breathe i was fatigued more
than anything else i was honestly that's
what it was it wasn't
tired you know i i had a realization uh
i tweeted this
i'm looking at what's going on in
australia where you've got the guys just
peppers pepper balling and it's fascism
that's that's i think over bio fashion
and i realized something though
i'm rich
i don't got to follow the rules i saw
the met gala and the emmys what do i got
to worry about
good we're good
it's all those people that are your
favorite if you're in a certain income
bracket then the rules don't apply to
you oh yeah that's how it works
absolutely i get it i've got i've got
the you know tanya where it says our
accounting off the table yeah yeah yeah
so i was watching and i'm like these
people they're being attacked this is
horrifying and i went wait a minute and
then i looked over at a picture of aoc
and i was like
i'm rich i don't got to worry about any
of that so all i got to do is make sure
i show my bank account to biden
obviously right of course and then they
give you your official you're rich and
you get out of it so this is the reason
i made this i'm making a joke obviously
is that the people who are advocating
for these policies where they will be
beaten by police and pepper sprayed on
the ground are not rich people the
people like aoc the political elites and
the ultra wealthy are going to these
events they are not being bothered with
but the peasants carry her dress for her
while they wear a mask just the peasants
and i i actually love that i think it's
vogue they did that like mini doc and
you can see the peasants are all they're
carrying the dress and they're all
masked and it reminds me of and it pains
me to say this but actually i think the
uh you know when you talk about all of
all the dystopias out there which one
are we closest to and i think it
actually is suzanne collins yeah i'm
afraid the hunger games right so in in
hunger games remember remember all the
servants in the so the capital is the
elites and everyone else is in out in
the districts right and then they they
send your kids to go off and die in
afghanistan excuse me i mean in the
hunger games right right and um
and then and you watch it on tv and
people can root for various sides and
then and the elites say oh more of that
please yes and uh and they have all
their crazy hairdos and crazy dresses
but
for all they call them the avoxes in in
hunger games and they all have their
tongues cut out the servants the
servants wow and when i was looking at
the when i was looking at the mask so
avoc no voice right and so when i was
looking at the all the servants
surrounding aoc with with the masks on i
just thought man they can't speak they
can't speak yeah
suzanne collins i gotta say she nailed
yeah but i gotta be honest it's um i
think it's a brave new fahrenheit 1984
for vendetta exactly so uh luke uh
roykowski has that shirt is that sure
yeah it's like you are here but i'm like
i think he's missing one i think it's
only he's only only got three because
you think about it it's like you got
1984 you got big brother censorship
spying surveillance you got brave new
world video games
instagram this dopamine you know
antidepressants you got fahrenheit 451
where they're banning all this different
stuff which is still very similar to uh
1984 but in fahrenheit 451 it was people
demanding the censorship because they
were offended by everything and then you
got v for vendetta you know viva
vendetta was in the movie at least
the virus happened right the virus yeah
locked everybody down what was the 19
zone what was the name of the party yeah
yeah oh the party um i don't what was
the party's name i can't think of it do
they have a name i don't i'm not sure
they did not like the new government or
the new government had a name or
something i forgot exactly but it was
the saint mary's virus i think it was
right yeah yeah young me park was saying
north korea is the hunger games right
now the so was it seoul it's the capital
north korea no pyongyang
south korea pyongyang is like the
capital right and everyone else is like
well eating human corpses i mean it's
like
no electricity right just
north korea and people get brought to
the capitol north korea experienced an
extreme
famine
in the 1990s
and so now what's going on
generationally is the famine generation
in north korea is attaining adulthood so
they are coming up and because they are
so stunted that their children are
having issues as well but also you also
had a population drop at that time
because of the starvation and so now
that's leading to a second famine
underneath all of this as well as just
the insane policies of that country
they're going to collapse
i was uh when i saw the met gala and the
emmys i'm like these are literally
hunger games villains it's crazy this is
the capital right i mean how can you not
how good it's it's you know i wish there
was some higher literature we compared
to but it really is hunger games yeah no
it's a it's a good point i mean they
they uh they're all dressed like you
know crazy but here's here's here's the
thing about the hunger games that i i
wonder if who is it suzanne collins
yeah did she know about behavioral sync
i'm done calling it wokeness i'm calling
it behavioral sync for now yeah
i mean think about it yeah you're
familiar with behavioral sync in the
right the right utopia experiments how
go uh enlighten me uh confined space
unlimited food and water and the rats
basically went insane oh yeah yeah yeah
yes i didn't really know that term yeah
but one of the things uh is the
beautiful ones one of the things uh that
emerged from it was what uh the
researcher called the beautiful ones who
would just groom themselves just not
constantly trying to poof up their hair
and be like looking really pretty while
doing nothing else get a selfie and
that's what i see as the met gala they
look ridiculous like plastic robot
people and i'm like these are the
beautiful ones
in their world of abundance with no
responsibility and instant gratification
they are those who are just sitting
there grooming each other then you get
the violence in the streets and those
are the crazy violent ones eric hoffer
in um in true believer um the great
longshoreman philosopher had this line
back in the 1950s where he said
um mass movements don't usually arise
among the working class because they are
working right mass movements generally
arise among the affluent and boards yes
yep
we got nothing else to do man no purpose
no direction well and also because
without having that without he was
essentially saying there is there's
something to the human psyche where in
human nature whereby in you to go
through a meaningful rite of passage
from adolescence into adulthood usually
that's that's work that's usually
through work through rigor through
taking the taking on of responsibility
uh the is sort of the mantle of
adulthood however when you you have a
certain level of affluence when you have
a certain level of abundance that never
happens and so you're now missing
something in your psyche that you're
constantly searching for and so that
these people will create these mass
movements in order to fulfill that
internal need that they have i want to
talk about the troops because we were um
we were talking about mandatory
vaccinations for the us military
and what most people told us is they
assumed that if you were in right now
and you said i won't get vaccinated you
would get an administrative discharge
did you have you heard anything like
that
that's that's uh ucmj
92.
that is your well it depends um
you know it's that essentially is is
more of a decision made by the military
but but it would be fair to follow
orders so they could give you
administrative discharge which is
uh sort of like the medium so there's
honorable of course honorable discharge
um there's administrative there and then
there's other than honorable oh so
dishonorable isn't the exact word these
other than honorable other than
honorable is that a new phrase
no i i've heard it before i just didn't
know it was formal so we have we have
the story from daily mail biden says
troops should which but i believe
honorably discharged i believe so hunter
i believe hunter has actually gotten
abandoned discharged as well that makes
sense yeah biden says troops should be
dishonorably discharged if they disobey
order to get covet vaccines so the house
is using the wrong phrase the house is
set to vote on the ndaa the pentagonal
defense budget so they mandated all 1.4
million service members get vaccinated
an amendment passed during committee
markup prohibits giving service members
who refuse a vaccine anything but an
honorable discharge white house said
that commanders must have the ability to
give orders and take appropriate
disciplinary measures including
enforcing the vaccine mandate the white
house also took issue with the section
of bill that exempts those who had the
previous covenant infection from the
vaccine mandate now that is insane so a
dishonorable discharge the difference
the difference between that is
dishonorable discharge means you it can
only be administered by a court martial
so that means you you're actually going
into a military trial uh that you've got
a jag you've got a military judge etc
you're facing charges uh and then that
whole process plays out so the other
ones that we were talking about were are
forms of administrative
but
for dishonorable discharge i mean
there's recycled discharge right there's
medical districts yeah a lot of people
obviously um if you know you can get
discharged for various reasons not
always something like negative um and
then when you're when you leave if you
want to retire if you want to resign if
you're an officer um that's still
considered a discharge a discharge by
itself doesn't necessarily mean
something negative occurs if you're uh
if you're an officer and you're working
everyone herbal everyone is discharged
right right
if you're an officer and your residents
honorable yes yeah so the anything on
other than honorable discharge would be
not uh dishonorable discharge that's a
different thing there's no court martial
what i'm saying is yeah dishonorable
discharge means that you've gone through
a court martial and you you are out
you're you're so you could have anything
other than honorable discharge without a
court martial so you're saying right
that would all find under very these
various forms of administrative
discharge
so it doesn't seem like the people who
refuse the vaccine as of right now will
be dishonorably discharged
no but biden wants that to be the case
but he says he wants it so that means
that means he wants to it you know to
carry out what he said which i don't
think he understands what he's talking
about even though uh he had two sons in
the military um he doesn't seem to know
very much about the military what do you
do when your commander surrenders a war
that you're winning and then makes
horrible decisions after that
you're crazy
you mean yeah you transferred to the air
force
but i mean legit is the generals in the
army when the commander does that what
are you supposed to do
uh well if it's rome um the centurions
would you know go to the you know go to
the senator or go to the emperor and and
demand some form of tribute the
praetorian guard of course would go and
demand a form of tribute from them well
like what are the generals supposed to
do if biden he surrendered us to the the
taliban and now he's like i i i was
saying i read more and more i think that
was on purpose huh i really i just more
and more you learn about what's going on
with the with the mineral deposits the
deal from china cutting with the taliban
you know it's there there's i wouldn't i
wouldn't want to say i believe it's
entirely probable or or even likely but
there's that possibility joe biden's
done deals with china and his son and
he's hooking them up this is why i tell
people to take the alaska pill because
we have so many mineral deposits under
our own soil that if we're worried by
the way about these deposits in
afghanistan well guess what flood the
zone right if we're putting our own
minerals in this then we're going to get
them they're going to be cheaper we're
going to be able to use them better we
don't need afghanistan and it's going to
hurt them in the world market too so we
need an authorization for use of
military force in alaska invade alaska
yeah we should invade alaska invade
occupy alaska nation buildings occupy
alaska nation building alaska 100 all
for it
dude
you know last time i was on here we
talked about this that these towns out
there they're the poverty is insane it's
it's it's it's a nice thought it really
really is i think it would require a lot
of private sector movements however in
terms of any kind of actual military
operation i got to say this story about
vaccinating our
our military
the military is being purged and the
police departments are being purged i i
mention this video every often every so
often where i think it was in uh
portland
there were these antifa people stalking
a guy who and they were yelling at each
other as he slowly walked backwards he
had some kind of bat or or bar and the
police pulled up ordered him on the
ground and arrested him the guy who was
actually being harassed and and you know
i wasn't was trying to defend himself
right and then he apologizes to antifa
saying sorry about that you know
is what happens
when the police
who are good are like i refuse to
enforce this stuff they quit what's left
behavioral sync police officers
woke police officers when the military
says if you defund the police you're
going the only place you're going to
have are the bad cops because all the
good ones are going to leave they're
going that's why
we're going to go out but with the
military they're doing the same thing in
turkey carlson said they're coming after
what did he say something like christian
conservatives christian conservatives so
go back go back to january i was
reporting this early on um even before i
was at human events and i said this
started with these pre-screening of the
national guard troops that were going to
be occupying the u.s capitol prior to
january 6. they were out there with the
the razor wire the fencing that i had to
drive past every single day i couldn't
even park my car when i was going to the
studio on american news because these
soldiers were out and they were asking
me for my identification papers for my
papers just so that i could go to work
at the same place that i had worked for
years right and they would say why are
you filming why are you feeling i'm i'm
a reporter i work for one america news
do you have do you have uh you know
credentials i think well i do but i'm
i'm also on a public street in the
nation's capital yeah right but so one
of the things that came out was remember
they were pre-screening people that were
deployed to the capitol what were they
looking for they were looking at some
flags gadsden flags maga hats turning
point usa
nra
yaf you know all these just like that's
very nice like a virginia basic or a
symbol in virginia they use in the
license right right it's a very basic
symbol
symbols of american conservatism or
patriotism and americanism the gadsden
flag i don't really think is i mean i
know the libertarians try very hard to
uh to claim it but it really is just an
american symbol at the end of the day
symbol of independence and that phrase
don't tread on me that's that's ben
franklin that was the idea that because
the rattlesnake was such a north
american uh creature that he said you
know this was something that
should be
it's not and that we should use because
it's ours and the british don't have it
and so you get all these uh
conservatives who are very confident
that they would win against the left one
of the original
one of the original memes of america if
you will except it's not true because if
it ever comes down to any kind of real
kinetic warfare the entire military and
the police departments will be wokified
by then and there are a lot of people
who are like i would never follow those
orders yeah that's right and they'd
court-martial you or throw you out and
then the remaining woke
lemming npc soldiers would do whatever
they're told like they did in dc well
and remember they're not going to be
told
that
you know oh hey these are just regular
american citizens they're going to be
told these are extremists these are
crazy and right fail far right anti-vaxx
um conspiracy nut jobs who believe that
they want to overthrow the country they
are planning an insurrection and you
need to uh go in and infiltrate this
group with you know get them to commit
crimes so that we can bring them up on
charges and you get to egg them on and
egg them on and then we're going to
arrest them all and you are saving the
country by doing this you see that event
in dc where it was for the j6 defendants
but everybody was a fed right it was the
funniest thing ford fisher got the uh
got the footage right so a fed actually
was there and got arrested the funny
thing is it's like
when you have a large crowd of thousands
of people and there's like seven feds
there you won't notice
they they all look fairly similar and
they're kind of obvious sometimes but
you've got so many people everywhere but
when no one shows up and the only people
there are feds they all look identical
they're wearing khaki shorts with the
sides of their heads shaved the same
haircuts the same sunglasses the same
watches and it's like what is this
sidearm greetings fellow
right right how are you
planning any insurrections
and
there was a one guy who got arrested
and the police surround him because he
had a gun and he's like my badge is in
my pocket and they pull out a badge some
people claimed he was undercover but
others claimed he was just an officer
who was there and i think the left was
trying to frame it as federal agents are
moga cultists and they're at these
events or was he recruiting
recruiting or was he recruiting in what
capacity like trying to get more feds
trying right trying to get this this is
the way it works right a federal
informant is not typically a federal
agent right right so a federal informant
is someone who has a relationship with a
federal agent which is known as a source
and a handler or an informant handler
right you are being run that's what
that's the parliament you're being run
by that agent so they're not going to
get somebody who has a badge and stick
them in the group and have them like you
know like ian is not going to be you
know you know the agent but ian's going
to be the one talking to the agent i saw
those signal messages it's all
theoretical by the way
uh big graphene i'll talk to anybody man
let's heal this earth hey man we're just
talking we're just talking but no so the
way it works is and then that and you've
seen this by the way in the michigan
governor operation and i'm calling it
the operation because that's what it was
the the text messages have been coming
out where you can see the relationship
it is being driven by the agent where
they're telling people to egg things on
to egg things on and to use the legal uh
the legal phrase you have to to commit a
um a conspiracy to commit a crime what
you need to do is you need to of course
first come up with the plan and then you
need to take an overt action in
furtherance of the conspiracy so what it
was in the michigan plot was because if
you're just talking about stuff okay
that's just talk you can't make a case
on that but and again i'm talking about
the legal you know situation so what
they do is they say hey we're going to
go get in the car and we're going to go
do recon and he says get everybody you
can tell them saturday whatever the day
you can he says what's better what
should i go saturday or sunday he
responds
go whichever day you can get the most
people
get them all in the car because the
agent knows that this is the way the
rules work so that if whoever is in that
car then and they're going around and
they're just like taking pictures around
the lake but it just so happens that
this is lake where the governor's
mansion is and so they can then put on
paper this was an overt act and
furtherance of the conspiracy what if
like you showed up with a bunch of
pizzas and you're like hey guys i
brought a bunch of pizzas for us to eat
and hang out they're like that's a
planning meeting
um you'd have to eat you'd no no i don't
i would have to be in furtherance of the
crime right right you know so that's
just that's just eating dinner people
need to understand when it comes to
talking to cops and
feds and all that stuff
they don't care about you they will use
you
and by the way one of those stories
to your point one of those stories one
of the informants is getting brought up
on charges yep you know so this is a guy
who was in on the operation but um and
of course the you know the speculation
is that maybe they're not being as as
forthcoming maybe they're not willing to
testify like they were and now guess
what they're getting slapped with
charges too there's a there's a bunch of
stories about this and i won't get into
specifics because i'm just like michigan
you know like privacy details and stuff
but there are there are big stories over
the past 10 years with federal
informants
who
cooperated and everything right and then
immediately once it was over got
arrested and charged
a lot of this was done during the early
2000s in the war on terror and it was it
was young muslims in the united states
american citizens who thought they were
talking to you know hamas or hezbollah
or al-qaeda and then eventually isis but
it always ended up being federal agents
who were posing i mean like there are
people
who have been contacted by the feds and
they'll be like would you like to help
us stop this crime and they'd be like
yes i will help you and then they start
saying like you know let me know what
you need they start working with the
feds to get them information and then
the feds come and arrest them like the
people like when they come to you and
say we're gonna have you be an informant
it's quite possible you're being
investigated
and they want you to say things oh yeah
they can lie to you oh yeah yeah yeah
you're an informant tell us what's going
on but yeah so they were saying this
they were doing this we're doing it this
guy was organizing against you you want
to you want to serve your country right
yep you care about your country don't
you you're patriot right right you're
not you're not one of those well that's
a traitor all right you would you
wouldn't do that you wouldn't you
wouldn't lie to a police officer would
you i was i was you wouldn't download a
tv would you i was kidding
one of my lie detector tests one of my
polygraphs that you have to do um the
the guy was so they do this thing where
you know that's supposed to be like the
test right before they get into the real
questions and then they say um you know
the guy was like no i just you want to
get the baseline and so i just wanted to
check so they ask you questions that uh
they assume you're going to lie on so
that they can get a baseline of what you
read what your reading is like and keep
in mind the machine they ask you
something they think you'll lie about
right like what so the question he asked
was you've never lied to your parents
have you
that's a good one
do people say i haven't lied to my
parents right because of course they're
thinking then that it's going to trigger
response of well of course i wouldn't
lie to parents and but actually the one
that he asked me if we go um and he
prefaced it he goes you know i'm a prior
state trooper and boy when i would pull
somebody over for speeding
oh my gosh you know i would know how
fast they went but i tell you what
if they were honest with me and if they
said you know what officer i i was going
a little fast back there i'm sorry about
that i would usually let him off with a
warning but if somebody lied to me
if somebody had the audacity to just lie
to my face and disrespect me like that
i was coming after them you you would
never do that right you would never lie
to a police officer right
so
keep in mind understand what they're
doing they're priming you right so
you're being primed to say oh my gosh
i'm going to be in trouble
if i tell this guy who keep in mind he's
he's the evaluator of the test and the
proctor the administer of the test right
so he's grading my answer to that is i'm
i i'm gonna be honest it's kind of
confusing i'm not quite sure what
you were getting right right honestly
when you when you when you make a really
really long question and then say you
would never do that i'm not quite sure
what that refers to huh you'd never lie
to a police officer would you i would
not lie to a police officer right and so
the and you you never have lied to
police officers i have never liked a
police officer or something
and so so that's the idea is that you
know because
they're they're trying to prime you into
a situation where you're going to tell
and it's a white you know it's a white
lie obviously i lied to my parents all
the time as a kid it's not a material
[Laughter]
the essential question is that you know
a machine can't tell if you're lying
right like we don't have machines that
we i don't think we'll ever have
machines that could do that what does it
do it measures your heart rate it
measures your respiration uh measure
there's there's little clips that
measure your sweat you know they have
one across your
uh your chest you have one kind of
across your lap you have one that you're
like sitting on a pad to get so they're
measuring various uh your physiological
signs but you can't tell if you're lying
yeah they're just like they're trying to
see all these different stressors light
up right so they're they're trying to
get a reaction out of you and that i
mean they're inadmissible
the the lie detectors to me which is why
they're inadmissible right right they're
fake right they're completely fake it's
not real like but but but yeah i had a
buddy who you know who was doing that um
uh it was called pcas was one of the
systems and uh he was doing it overseas
for some third country nationals that
were coming on base and so he was um
that would work as like other
constitutional workers and so he was he
was doing pcas on them
anyway you know one thing he said was
we are evaluated not necessarily by the
amount of people that we conduct but
we're actually evaluated by the amount
of elicitations that come out of this
because essentially what you're doing is
for for most people you know for your
general normie out there you're you're
putting them into this high stress
environment you're telling them that i
will know if you are lying so you better
come clean you better tell me so they
start to ask a question and they say you
know have you ever taken home government
documents have you ever taken home
government resources and then they'll
say
i'm going to step away from the machine
for a second you know when i was asking
that question i could there was i was
getting
a weird reading and i wasn't really sure
what it was it just seemed like
something was registering with you just
as i was saying the question so is is
there something you want to tell me
that maybe could help me word the
question better so that this test this
evaluation can be more accurate to
explain the situation so if you just
tell me that i'll write it down and i'll
i'll i'll refurbish this question and
reevaluate it for you and people spill
their
guts yeah it just seems like polygraphs
for the most part are put people in high
stress situations where they think they
have to tell the truth right exactly and
it makes them panic and
then it's just it's not real yeah in
interrogation it's it's known as
emotional fear up
so it's emotional fear up with you know
uh you know a very elaborate um i got a
better one what we'll do is we'll take
two gigantic metal discs hooked up with
a bunch of wires yes and we'll just and
we'll have them hooked up to the
polygraph and be like don't worry about
the giant metal disks they just blast
you with intense radiation whenever you
lie but you're not gonna lie so it
doesn't matter yeah yeah maybe you're
fine you know if you're not gonna lie
then you will die from radiation
actually just step out for a second we
just gotta test them every time you lie
and grab the sponge every time you allow
you have to eat polonium just so you
know just a little bit just a little bit
a little bit not a lot we wouldn't we'd
make you make it a lot of fun i mean
like a tiny little bit which will kill
you it does like
wouldn't that tiny little bit just kill
you just like you start disintegrating
your dna or whatever yeah
completely
not immediately by the way yeah that's
what the didn't that didn't navalny get
polonium uh i don't know if it was
navalny i think it was one it was um
somebody got polo not powell it was it
was in the uk yeah it was one of the
ones that they had had ascribed to
polonium's radium disintegration by
synthetically bombarding bismuth with
lead or bismuth or lead with neutrons
you get this polonium stuff yeah
it's radiation it's radioactive yeah it
goes into your body and then
it's not it's not immediate or anything
but but yes so it's not it's like it's
like ricin which would be much more
immediate
yeah people got to pay attention to the
stuff they eat man
because something number one yeah you
know that's why when i hear people say
that hey man it comes from the earth i'm
like i don't know man a lot of stuff
comes from the earth that's not exactly
the best argument yeah i don't uh people
send me food in the mail
and i'm just like oh that's really great
and i throw in the trash i can't eat it
i'm like what am i gonna do give it to
somebody else but some people might take
it and be like no i'll keep it i'm like
okay that's your choice but i like i
went through a phase where i would read
all the ingredients and if i saw
something i didn't know i'd look it up
online and read how does this interact
with my body and i'd read all about it
good question yeah i'm just that's great
that's great by the way yeah that's
that's good donald trump would only eat
fast food
you know why that's exactly why because
when you go to a place and you ask
someone to prepare food for you he
wouldn't like exclusively but almost
exclusively he was eating fast food and
there are two big reasons i was told by
some people in the press corps was one
he was a germaphobe he is he felt like
these fast food chains had standards and
so that if he ate from these places
there was at least it was less likely
that he would get sick compared to going
to any other restaurant
two
when you walk in and say i want a big
mac it's pre-made and sitting right
there
so no one could spit in his food or
smear stuff on it or do something gross
super troopers yup yup and there are a
lot of people who don't like the man but
more importantly is a celebrity so a lot
of people might sound like he's going in
himself too or what it's not like he's
going in himself too
right but it's just when they already
have the big mac sitting on that little
warmer and you order a big mac and fries
they just go right i've actually so
there was that um i know people saw that
that tweet that um
i had tweeted a picture of him out um
and it was actually he was with sean
parnell but then i clipped i i cropped
shawn out sorry sean him super thin and
it was like he was looking really thin
and i and i just tweeted out he how is
he getting younger right so it went kind
of viral and then
i get an envelope at the studio uh down
in dc
and and i open it up and it's it's a
note from
it says from the desk of john j trump
he's printed out my tweet and then and
then and then written thanks jack you
are looking great too
keep up the great work
that you decided donald trump so when
you when you absolutely have to respond
to it so then i tweeted that out which i
i have to look into the process but some
people were saying like that should
definitely be your nft jack like that
that tweet of trump's printed out tweet
that he responded to you which then i
then tweeted
yeah that's amazing it's like when you
when you absolutely have to comment on
the tweet yeah but you're not on twitter
how do you do it
let's talk about one of the best oh
sorry sorry sorry the um the little bit
of the backstory though was i was told
not by him but someone else i was
discussing this all with that they are
start that they are they he's cutting
down on the fast food
i was told that he's cutting down on the
fast food um and
keto uh more steak a lot they said hey
man eat more steak and it was
sure i'll eat more steak why not you
know that sounds like a good diet yeah
you gotta get all that sugar
he's at mar-a-lago he's at bedminster
he's at trump tower so i mean it's his
right it's it's restaurants that he
controls it's his staff etcetera you
know you know what people need to
understand about uh ketone stuff
a lot of the garbage you eat is the
processed breads grains sugars
and i've noticed that when i've been
trying to stay away from all the sugars
i'm also staying away from processed
foods yeah so it's a lot more fresh
chicken breasts a lot more roast beef
fresh cheeses we have raw cheeses so my
wife's family um and my wife of course
they're from from eastern europe when
they come to the us they
like my father-in-law like he will not
eat processed food here he he looks at
it and said this is not food like this
this is plastic this is fake i don't
know what this is but you go to he gets
something from um whole foods or the
butcher or something that they get and
they cook themselves okay this is food
right um but when it comes to the
processed stuff like i've seen him just
you know you know we'll have some
chicken nuggets for like the kids or
something and hey do you want no like
just emphatically i just had a feeling
that uh grain fed beef maybe isn't as
keto as grass because grain is if it's
eating grain it's whole life then maybe
it's got some stuff in it that's not
well you do have to watch for i was
actually tweeting about this earlier
today like if you're eating beef you
have to make sure you're not eating
double plus good beef
um
because because there are
uh
at some of these factory farms they're
depending on what they feed that's why
you want um free range grass-fed because
they are feeding
these cows um corn you know corn and
stuff with all this estrogen and putting
all sorts of additives in to to make it
bigger to make it juicier to make it
last longer but guess what it's also not
healthy that's right they feed salmon
farm salmon is fed corn yeah and then i
read i read that like in nature salmon
turns pink because of the krill and
stuff that it eats or whatever right in
farms they're fed corn so they're gray
so they have to add food coloring gross
yeah
amazing isn't it i almost just spit out
my coconut
food coloring bad all right we got some
comments synthetic food coloring look
out i want to talk about comics check
this out this is hilarious uh so from
bounding into comics here the story dc
comics pokes fun and anti-vaxxers with
anti-saver movement in superman vs lobo
number one i don't think it's funny that
they're making superman fight lobo but i
digress you basically have like lois
lane oh superman always fights logo no i
know but like as like the main villain
oh yeah you know in this in this
capacity so uh we have
lois lane who is apparently like she
looks like she's a 26 year old
angsty goth of some sort intern yeah and
she's got someone filming her on a cell
phone where she's like
you know lobo claims to support america
and be a patriot but he's actually you
know look what he's doing to the flag
and so they have this this this
depiction of these uh of these people
this woman says superman didn't bother
to ask her about her fear of heights
when he flew her away from a fire
this one says superman's powered by
radioactivity and making people sterile
and what the hell is an anti-saver and
it says don't interfere with god's is
that auntie
i suppose anti-vaxxer anti-saver auntie
you know what's you know what's funny
because i was looking at this and then i
see this this this art right here where
it shows lois and she's got like her
hair over one eye and she's looking up
and she's supposed to be like the cool
anti-anti-vaxxer
speaking the truth on the web saying
he's lying to you this is lois lane for
stay in your lane please like and
subscribe thank you and i'm like i just
want to make one thing really clear for
people
that is not
cool no you know like
lois lane being like the establishment
and big pharma that's what we're all
into that's the cringiest cringe that's
ever created did you see the kaiser
chiefs
the kaiser cheeks did you see the viral
kaiser chiefs video no no it's kind of
jesus did you not see this one you're
gonna love this
when at a concert
the some guy from the kaiser chiefs goes
everybody raise your hand oh wait wait
wait wait no i did see this i didn't
they realized that's right yes yes yes
and he's like your hands are clean
washing them let's hear it for pfizer
and then there's a guy and he's like
crying he's like yes
so like when you have a comic book and
lois lane supposed to be like all cool
and she's like he doesn't like america
and anti-savers are bad i'm like kind of
crazy that's that's not actually it like
they think they're still the cool
confident and charismatic they're
actually the creepy weirdos raising
their hands and going washing your hands
but trump supporters are the cultists
yeah yeah well there there are the trump
there is the trump cult it's just not
mainstream influential and it's not
dominant in the right it's just they
exist you have a dominant
influence network on the left that is
pervasive throughout uh media throughout
entertainment throughout academia and
anything they say goes
now you know
i'm also someone who thinks that you
know inoculation makes sense having
antibodies is a good thing obviously
that helps that's science but when you
throw it and shove it down people's guts
like this or shove down people's throats
like this it's you and you and you
wonder why aren't people you know just
doing as they're told why don't people
just shut up and put this thing inside
them right you know it's it's you know
you have to wonder that look meet people
where they are just just meet people if
someone says talk to them
they're literally just have a
conversation so we they also don't have
superman and lois lane smacking you in
the face with it they they include this
uh patton oswalt tweet where he says
haha the new superman versus lobo has
anti-saver idiots who are against
superman helping them and i'm like
uh first of all that joke was done in
the incredibles when mr incredible saves
a guy who jumps off a building and then
he gets injured and sues him saying
that's right that's right yeah that's
the whole but more importantly that's
the whole plot originally if someone
says superman don't touch me superman
don't touch them it's the weirdest thing
that they're like could you imagine
someone not wanting to be saved by
superman i'm like there's probably a lot
of circumstances which someone for
whatever reason decides they don't want
superman touching them and this is what
these people fundamentally don't
understand about liberty i mean like
people who have dnr's
yes exactly sure
but but i mean if someone's like in a
burning building and they see superman
and they scream save me like i get
superman's gonna save them he's not a
real person these things don't actually
happen but i'm like if someone literally
says
i understand superman saves people
don't touch me
that okay
why would you make i see this what they
don't understand about liberty when i
see people saying like i'm going to go
get vaccine and i'm like that's very
nice that's very excellent i'm glad that
you've made a good choice for yourself
and you're happy no i mean it
they there there's there the two sides
in this are basically like the stupid
people don't do what they're told and
the other side saying do whatever you
want leave me alone you have rights
yes rights exist
rights are real we believe in them i
just i look at this and i'm kind of like
dude
it's really weird that they've become
the pure flicks they've become like the
this is why by the way the stuff that
like iconic comics and comics gate and
some of the ethan van scriver of these
guys that's why so much of that is
taking off right um some of these guys
have posted their
um their revenue just over the past five
years and the numbers are it's millions
and millions of dollars because the fans
are checking out look look i'm going to
tell good stories imagine over 70 80
years 90 years 100 years even you have
created this formula for entertainment
this system of entertainment comic books
and movies and we've figured out what
works and we're like these are fun
stories these are good ideas we want to
evolve them we want to adapt them we
want to come up with new unique ideas we
want to inspire people and then all of a
sudden one day the biggest industry says
we're going to pivot
away from the stuff that people like yes
into stuff they don't like perfect and
then all of a sudden the entire
multi-billion dollar industry opens up
and they're li there there stands some
regular folks who are like i would like
to make comics for this gigantic
multi-billion dollar empty space so it's
no no surprise i don't get tons of money
by the way one thing we should probably
mention
who's the target audience for comic
books young dudes is it is it adults is
it is it people over eight over the age
of 18 i don't think so it's 13 14 yeah
so when i was reading them adolescence
should i get my three times
i give my three-year-old comic books he
doesn't quite understand all the plots
but he can you can see the characters he
loves them yeah
they're trying to alter the mediums that
kids read and to make them think these
things are cool and stuff that's that's
why i think this image of lois lane was
the funniest thing to me because
the people right now
who are yelling clean hands washing them
like they are the uncritical thinking
individuals they are the npcs they are
not viewed as active contributors
and cool i mean certainly there are some
people who view them as as cool i
suppose because they just see them on
youtube but they're not edgy they're not
like the way they depicted her is she's
like not in my country and here's one i
hope not in yours next time we'll
discuss whether lobo called star wars
totally inaccurate
what does that even mean what what does
it mean that star wars is totally
inaccurate
no quite literally as like a star wars
fan what does that mean uh well i mean
it wouldn't make sense because star wars
happened in a galaxy far far away in a
long time ago
we'll even know about that but what is
what is inaccurate well i'm saying like
in their universe he saw star wars and
said it was inaccurate what does that
mean it's a fantasy movie
people who are making this have no idea
what criticism or culture is having to
do with so
there's you know
somebody was talking about this and and
and um we just lost the you know the
greatest one ever do it nor mcdonald and
people were talking about comedy and how
this is how comedy has changed over the
years
and i don't think it was norm but it was
it was in an article that someone was
talking about i think was patrice
o'neill was saying that
comedy changed when people stopped being
allowed to be offensive and so in a good
comedy is half the room laughing and the
other half horrified um and when you
can't step on cultural taboos anymore
then you're not seeking laughter you're
seeking applause
you know what it is man and that's what
this is they are seeking applause
claptor it is time to stop acting like
we are one country it's the it's the
stupidest thing when i i see tweets from
people and they're like i can't under i
can't believe it took the mainstream
media this long to verify the hunter by
an email
seeing those two and i'm like i just
laugh i do yeah do you tweet out when
like a you know a a country in
tajikistan finally uh just you know
publishes documents on like a new
scientific research that america has
been working on for the past decade are
you like wow tajikistan finally figured
out how to do antimatter generation
which is huge we're seeing this
no we don't care what they think we we
as americans know how anti-matter how to
create it how to contain it it's very
very difficult it's very very very very
very expensive but boy can you make
powerful weapons we're not sitting here
every day being like wow finally
kazakhstan's we're publishing you know
you know scientific articles and
we we don't we don't do that so when a
news story breaks and we all verify it
and we know it's real and then
nine months to a year later some foreign
country the the the you know blue states
of stan are like we've finally figured
it out we're like yeah that's nice it
has nothing to do with us it doesn't
affect us in any way it's almost um
you know it's almost like it's almost
like the right should start doing
culture like i don't know like maybe
like a children's book series that you
know that caters to traditional american
values i'm just i'm just i'm just saying
yes
perhaps like a children's book from mr
jackpot
kind of you know it just just so happens
that you know for once i'm not doing the
my pillow promo for
yes um but
culture is very very important we must
build it up um let's jump over to this
article this is funny
i had i was scrolling bounding into
comics and i saw a picture of your face
and i was like oh that's funny sitting
right in front of me jack bosok
announced his new children's book to
fight back against teachers in hollywood
pushing communism
comic book creator and senior editor at
human events check behold recently
announced a brand new children's book
the island of free ice cream yes that's
amazing um so this sounds like a very uh
complex and in-depth universe you've
created here about the island of ice
cream uh tell me jack
tell me about the island of free ice
cream so we're doing this it's part of
the brave book series you go to
bravebooks.us we're not doing amazon no
cancellations no money in jeff bezos
pocket to fly over us in his blue origin
rocket and laugh down at the at the
pores with our masks on while he wears
his dress um no this is so you go to
bravebook.us it's actually a series of a
shared universe that we're doing i
mentioned before ashley sinclair is
doing one the hodge twins are doing one
coming out um we have like a pro-life
one that's coming out we have some we
have some other really big names that i
can't talk about yet but they're coming
to be announced pretty soon here i think
october we have a really big one
dropping so the first is like a 12 issue
series and they're all sort of this
interlocking universe um part of this
big country called uh i think it's
called freedom it's not called freedom
of state of course and um they live
that's actually called freedom island um
and so we're we're planning for damastan
well we've got free island so so we'll
go to war eventually
and so they're in this this town of
washington and they have this market and
in the marketplace all the animals shop
and they go out and there's there's a
market and part of it sells ice cream
and there's character asher and he's a
fox and he's out there with his friends
and you know some people start
complaining because the ice cream in the
market is a little bit expensive and
they say you know what this ice cream is
too expensive and we don't like this
well along one day comes a group of
wolves and the wolves say
come to our island because on our island
the ice cream is free
so if you just come just just follow us
we'll put you on the ferry put you on
the boat and you come to our island and
and we have free ice cream as much as
you want you can eat to your heart's
desire
of course the only trick is that when
you get to the rally you actually see
this on the cover that uh their island
is has this beautiful sign on it but the
island is surrounded by a giant like
berlin wall covered covered in graffiti
and and the wolves are actually running
it like a huge prison camp and yeah and
their version of ice cream is
essentially like like gruel and it is
perfectly free um also you're not
allowed to leave the the island of free
ice cream and uh i do have a correction
there what do you got uh he's hang
gliding not being ferried in no he's
this this comes up later actually in the
story you gotta you've got to read the
book breaks into east germany yeah
that's actually how he escapes oh okay
yeah so it's sort of like a cross
between east germany cuba you know like
the island
um
and uh so that's actually how he escapes
and there's a there's a catapult
involved it's pretty fun very cool and
and so it's it just teaches people you
know the idea is no such thing as free
ice cream if something seems too good to
be true it probably is but it's it's a
cool story right and there's characters
and there's action
and the idea is you know hey we were
complaining about this expensive ice
cream but then the guy said the ice
cream was free but it turned out to be
you know much worse then of course you
know the main character goes back and
says no you have to stop listening to
the wolves don't trust them you can't
believe them they're like why they have
free ice cream why wouldn't we listen to
the wolves they're free ice cream wolves
they're really good you hate ice cream
you're you're just an anti-wolf fight
you know
uh no but they should actually if we do
a revision we'll have to trent get on
that um
and um
so it's it's it at the end though
there's a section where there's sort of
like a q a for you know parents
educators to sort of like and it you
know it's like jack says you know you
know and ask do what did it mean that it
was expensive would it mean that it was
free what you know what should you be
you know should you trust everything
that you hear should you trust every
offer that's out there and the cool
thing is is that brave books is now
working with um
homeschool groups which of course as
everybody knows is skyrocketing right
now through covid and through this crazy
woke crt stuff that people can finally
look over the screens because of zoom
one of the like the actual like
unintended consequences of this is that
people can actually see how their
children are being indoctrinated with
this crap in the school room on your
dime by the way private schools and
public schools and
then they want to check out so we're
working with homeschool groups working
with christian groups work with other
religious groups to be able to get this
book out and get the series out to them
and it and it is a series so you get um
we actually do like a subscription so
there's going to be 12 in the first
series you do a subscription you get one
a month and there's actually a huge
poster that you got to get you a poster
yeah i'm i'm being a terrible guest of
this right i should have actually
brought you one of them um so it's a
poster and then you get a sticker for
each book that you read and then it
reveals more of the story as you guys
nice cool yeah
freedom island
why don't we go to super chats and see
the people have to say
oh what is this we're getting a weird
so there's a really funny thing that
happens sometimes where
youtube on youtube's end it freezes but
on our end it's like
not and people often point out that it's
like a particular point to the
conversation we're not frozen here in
real life i'll tell you let me tell you
something okay
when i was in the field my my
main segment today was about the
defector saying china intentionally
released kobit yeah the moment i went to
put it up youtube started changing it
wouldn't let me do it i said i could
monetize it things are disappearing it
wouldn't save it said no it could be
kicked it back and so i just sat back
and i waited and i kept trying to save
it and eventually let me do it and i'm
like
you know there's a lot of things i talk
about that i know youtube probably
wouldn't care about but for some reason
whenever it comes to chinese communist
party stuff we get problems notably when
we talked about the 50 cent army on one
episode as soon as it was said
you two on the youtube's end it freezes
and we see all the f's in the chat and
then it jumps back in cutting out that
conversation
but anyway
i just saw that that's what i brought up
so let's go to super chat by the way
real quick um got a message in from tom
sauer a fellow navy officer he says
dishonorable discharge requires a felony
conviction at the court martial and
almost always comes with a prison
sentence like something that would land
you in prison in the real world so it
sounds like biden doesn't know what he's
talking about no so when so like to get
a dishonorable plus the court martial
like you have to have like a legit
seriously unfavorable outcome like you
did something that is like like you
committed like a straight-up crime
like not refusing a vaccine
smash that like button unless you change
it if you haven't already share the show
if you like it subscribe and go to
timcast.com to get that sweet sweet
members only content we've got more
members only content coming up really
really soon because we're preparing to
launch the new shows so uh we're
actually
there's a lot of work about behind the
scenes trust us it's like it's really
difficult to get all the stuff done
quickly but we we do we had meetings on
our new mystery show we have the music
being produced and we're getting really
close to launching it's going to be a
weekly show on the podcast uh on itunes
and spotify it's going to be like a 15
to 20 minute you know story reading with
cool sound effects and music and then
we're doing the members only version of
the show is where various individuals
will hang out and talk about the
mysteries and the ghosts and the ufos
and the true crime and the spooky
stories and the rate utopia but more
in-depth not news focused so like
bigfoot and just really crazy stories
meant to be like tales of intrigue i
don't i don't necessarily think bigfoot
is actually something that might come up
but the stories are typically a little
darker than that you know like we've got
one about irish mafia murders in new
york shane does an amazing job writing
these stories that being said let us
read some of these super chats you know
that uh that area in philadelphia that
it's always get getting shown with all
like the math and the addicts and
everything
that you know that video that where
people are like right right slowly
driving past right so that's that's
that's referred to as uh kensington
beach that that whole area um used to be
run it's called kensington and allegheny
so those streets intersect there there
used to be a huge irish mafia in
philadelphia called the k a gang and
they ran that specific area so they got
run out the irish got run out
not's fallen look what it is now all
right the mercenary says tim my county
in tennessee has over 10 000 students
opt out of mass mandates it's nice to
see people make a stand love the show as
always hey thank you appreciate it cool
beast
jonathan galterini says msm is finally
talking about how the most hesitant
group to get vaccinated are those with a
phd i guess they did their own study to
validate it wow yeah and i don't
necessarily know why that is because i
don't see people as as with phds as
being
necessarily smarter than anybody else
getting a phd just means you have
you spent more time staring at something
exactly it doesn't mean
it means you're a specialist in a field
for the most part so if someone's like i
have a phd in what uh you know
microbiology i'm like that's really
great you can tell me a whole lot about
that but can you explain anything about
economics no i know you're a specialist
in microbiology so like awesome cool
yeah when it comes to phds
just because someone has a phd doesn't
mean anything they have a phd in
economics okay so what does that have to
do with the vaccine well indicates that
they have a strong attention to detail
and a good attention span usually i
don't believe that's correct that
they're willing to pour over data i mean
yeah i don't can't really get your phd
without pouring over data yeah but it
doesn't it's more so
like tedium
it is dealing with the boring text
yeah and then and then a bunch of other
people vote and be like okay we agree
you can have one
oh great
all right let's see what we got
reuben uh pedroza jack do you think
china would nuke their capitalist model
to demonize the west and consolidate
power the people of china that i meet
say there's an astronomical gap between
the rich and the poor
i mean i mean sure right so so china has
this this this system of which has been
described in the past as almost like a
hyper capitalism when it comes just to
their markets um but you have to
understand that and we don't have time
to get in all this but there there a lot
of these enterprises like evergrand
which is the one china evergrand this
real estate um company that's going bust
right now they essentially operate as
shadow banks so this is these are all
shadow banking zombie banks that are
constantly and in the past throughout
which have been constantly bailed out by
the ccp like you want to talk about
money printer gopur in the us over there
it's yuan printer go burr like it is
massive and building going so and
building go boom because you're building
ghost cities um i i would see this when
i lived in shanghai that you would you
would have these guys you know you know
you the building would get painted like
once a month right you know you don't
need paint on the building guys you did
it last month we do it again because
it's all these make work projects it's
constantly going on why because one of
the biggest issues facing the ccp in
terms of the legitimacy is unemployment
if you have a one to two percent
unemployment
spike in the u.s you know that's an
issue if you have a one to two percent
percent population
because the population unemployment
spike in china
you have a revolution yep yeah so uh one
thing i talk about when it comes to
populations is scaling scaling problems
if you have a thousand people who live
in a small city you know what percentage
of them need to revolt and actually to
actually change something a large
portion because you're only going to
have a few hundred people but in a place
like manhattan where you have 2.5
million on the island and you've got you
know molten
and i think it's 10 million or whatever
in the in the metro 13
surrounding areas
0.01 maybe
like a few thousand people people
understand they see these massive
protests and they're like wow look how
many people are protesting it's like
that's 20 000. especially with how tight
the roads are on manhattan you can
actually do
but
there's uh what is it like 30 30k cops
in new york city yeah and so what if 50
000 people protest the police would be
overwhelmed to just leave right that's a
very very very tiny proportion of the
total population of new york
all right little tails farm says tim our
chicks are doing great just put 12 more
in the incubator and chicken city is
nearly done when you are ready for milk
goats we will send you a baby triple
registered nigerian dwarf from our herd
i'll take it yes the new chicken city
we're building the guy who just said he
wouldn't take food in the mail it's a
goat
what are they gonna do they're gonna
they're gonna give the goat some kind of
secret mission oh yeah no that might be
peter darshak on the other end of that
be careful we had a hawk attack
the hawks swooped down yeah yeah
yelled ran away the hawk bailed out did
you get anything no um one of the
chickens looked like it was fruffled
like it got hit right in a flyby but
totally fine just like the feathers were
sticking up yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah she preened well they do that to
kind of
try to ward off uh the new thing we're
building is gonna it's gonna go down
about a foot and a half or two feet into
the ground with like uh fencing and then
it's gonna be totally enclosed all over
so the coop we have now is totally
enclosed but the chicken run isn't the
new thing we're building is going to be
totally enclosed with a totally enclosed
chicken run
so we're legit making a chicken fortress
now the problem is we have
we we had the original seven and then we
had three babies because out of like 14
eggs they just didn't make it yep right
some of them weren't fertilized some of
them rotted and i had to try and pick
and choose which ones were the routed
ones and i think one of them may have
you know not been rotted but ultimately
we ended up with three
one's a rooster
we named him roberto jr because it's
roberto the rooster's only son but now
we have five black star chickens which
are special sex link breed from the
rhode island red and the bard plymouth
rock
three cockrells i don't know what we're
gonna do with these guys
because
maybe if they're big enough we can let
them like hang out once they're fully
adult in like a year maybe are you
saying you've got too many roosters in
the hen house too many roosters they're
not in the hen house not yet but um it's
already bad enough we've got the baby
rooster growing up and they're they're
in the same area but they're separated
they can't interact with each other but
they can see they can interact they can
see each other and gobble and pluck or
whatever but they can't actually right
because baby's too small but um i think
we can handle one ex another rooster but
we can't handle three and we got three
you know baby roosters that are coming
baby cockrells and they're gonna
we'll have to figure that one out as
time comes even the amish take their
roosters far away from where they sleep
it's going to be very very jarring there
because we're moving chicken city right
outside my bedroom windows
interesting year finally i'm going to be
your bedroom anymore ian
all right jinx mcninja says sorry tim i
can't tap the like button i can only
crush it just like lydia will continue
to crush sour patch kids with their
larger friends
very good
very good excellent
i've crushed them euphoric breaks has
been keto eight years now lost lots of
weight and at 50 years old i'm on
zeromeds welcome to the fat burner club
uh i didn't start doing it because i was
uh worried about my weight although many
people have given us nice comments
saying tim you're looking good no it was
more so that um one day we ordered a
bunch of crab and i didn't eat any
breads or sugars and i was like
i guess i won't and then i didn't and
then within a few days i was skating
better i was not tired i was feeling a
million times better and i was just like
i'm just gonna keep doing this i've been
doing it for about 10 years it'll be
it'll well just sort of like the low
carb low glycemic index right staying
away from bread staying away from sugar
trying to stay away from processed food
pastas you know um i think yeah next
year will be 11. yeah i've legit been
like doing uh a lot of cream
you know we have these keto bars they're
so amazing this is from a company called
boo foods okay
and i saw an ad for it once and they
have this keto cookie dough it's
basically cashew butter but it's
flavored like cookie dough and it's
delicious it's also these protein bars
we've got a bunch of yeah when i started
doing it there was like nothing right
there and and people would look at you
like crazy if i'm like why i i don't
want any bread with you you're at a
restaurant you're ordering they're like
what kind of bread do you want i don't
want any bread so do you want rolls i i
know i don't want any bread
breadsticks no
do you want pasta no
right and then they just go can you or
you know the other one is can you put
that on lettuce right yes yeah that
works great and but it is it is becoming
bigger and now you're starting to see a
lot of these products come up a lot more
companies come up realizing look folks
bottom line if you see something that
says low fat stay away from it run and
run away from that sugar because that
means it's full of sugar i'm not even
you know i i'm not even focused on
trying to do any kind of specific diet
diet i say keto because like it's a lot
of fat and a lot and you know no very
little sugar and less meat just like a
lot of the fats cream cheese avocado
stuff like that but i also just
i'm not thinking about it when i go out
to eat if there's something i won't i
won't do bread because that just always
screws me up but when i order stuff once
you get off bread and then you go back
to it no you feel terrible yeah it's
awful
absolutely terrible exactly but when you
feel this nasty after all i'll i'll have
uh
you know i'll have uh whatever meal even
it's got potatoes or something but keep
in mind americans it's natural and like
normal and healthy you might american
bread is very different than european
bread sugar yeah
potassium
full of that stuff found a yoga mat
that's something where you know that's
again you know having uh my wife being
from europe you know she just talks
about this stuff all the time like i
don't know what you guys do with your
bread i don't know why you do milk you
know so we don't look in europe so
different so we don't give it to our
kids we don't uh like we don't have
white bread in the house we don't ever
touch any of that stuff big question why
is potassium bromate used in bread it is
this preservative i think yeah well
preservative i mean i know why but why
is it there why why it's banned in
europe it's so dangerous they put it in
yoga mats it's crazy that it's in the
bread an evening agent or something
let's take some more super chats the
other one is seed oil folks see since
we're on on the topic seed oil which is
also known as rapeseed yep
all right we got shark bite biz says tim
great show love jack on some days even
ian can our youtube show shark bite biz
get a shout out we are about small
business growth thanks david strasser
should be a guest on tim cast irl thank
you for the super chat yeah
for jack david a says why do civilians
pledge allegiance to an icon while the
president members of the military and
civilians take an oath the constitution
why do civilians pledge to an iconic
flag
i pledge allegiance to the flag well the
flag isn't the president i'm a little
confused why are civilians pledging
allegiance to the flag but the president
police and military swearing oath to the
constitution
uh well i i think that the flag in
general is representative to the
republic and of course that's the word
that's said in the pledge um so the flag
is there as a representation of the
republic whereas in the military of
course that is a legally binding pledge
so you are binding so you need a legal
specific legal document that created our
republic so i think the inherent
tie between the two is that one's
representative of our republic one is
the document that created our republic
but it still has to do with the american
republic
all right ew says jack important
question the other day you put out a
tweet about insider info
about the administration discussing
cutting off intel sharing with india and
japan and the leaders of india and japan
being furious about it why are we not
hearing anything about that anywhere
so keep in mind um i wasn't saying they
were cutting it off i was talking about
the awk os treaty this is the thing that
uh partially led to the extreme anger
with between france and australia and
the us regarding the situation with the
submarines um i've actually been talking
to a french mep about this so it's a if
you're watching if you're a war room fan
shows a lot of warping fans out there
the signal not the noise um that
it's a situation where
look if you're crying trying to create a
intel sharing agreement that's going to
put china in a box
sure do we want the us on board of
course do we need australian board
obviously that's their backyard but why
would you not include india and japan
who literally share either borders or
territorial water waters with uh with
china and as well as south korea that
these are our allies right in the area
if you're going to do something like
that and be serious you cannot cut them
off
all right ega says tim you often bash
public schools and as a teacher myself
feel you're wrong in some aspects try
getting one on the show sometime all
teachers are bad every single one
abolish teachers
i'm kidding
i had a few really good teachers
mostly had average and disinterested
teachers and then i had it shows too
many really bad teachers too many really
bad teachers that shows too yeah yeah
actually i think it's probably fair to
say
the plurality of teachers i had were bad
i had only like two or three teachers i
thought were good yeah yeah same yeah
like two three maybe and so your whole
life in the word being being you know so
i i and you can remember their names
can't you i remember the name that's
what i'm saying i can't remember the
names of all my teachers yeah they
stepped into high school and i started
getting different classes right but in
high school do you remember the good
teachers oh yeah mr strooby john what's
up dog geometry right
we even had i even have a there was even
a good teacher in in my high school that
i started i still remember him i
remember his name never actually took
one of his classes but he used to sit
with us at lunch and just talk politics
and history and all sorts of stuff and
he was awesome just awesome who's that
i don't want a doctor oh
all right that's fair oh okay jl or his
initials for anyone out there
the former kennedy kendrick catholic
high school uh alumni
youtube is dying says stop bullying ian
with a crying emoji i think we need to
build it ian more oh why resistance
because resistance builds strength yes
exactly
we need we need to strengthen the boy
he's gonna be bullied so much like
within a year people won't realize he'll
be like six foot five and he's fast
he'll have like a massive chest and he
won't even realize no one will and then
look back i started making internet
videos in 2006 i've gone through cycles
of trauma learning how to deal with the
internet text because it was so new at
that time and none of my friends ever
had experienced it were you elite
i was i became lead because but you
learn not to take anything personally
including the positive or the negative
people say i love you you don't take it
personally because they're talking about
their own experience through you using
you as like this
you know focusing agent but they're just
saying their own experience how is that
different from regular love
it's very different jack okay all right
guardsmen nor heim of the 10th first
says you guys keep talking about alaska
as an alaskan i can tell you we live
under the boot of washington oregon in
california 100 it sucks that we are just
the lower 48s park and i'm your
entertainment huh that's go i mean and
and you know dale turner of course talks
about that as well but uh
alaska for alaskans let the alaskans
make their own decisions on this stuff
100 percent
alex stevens says somewhere somehow in
your holy fouchy skit you need to find a
way to include a declaration of holy war
or fouchy ouchies against the unvaxed so
in our uh that was our bonus segment
what did the guy say in in the the
project veritas
yeah
yeah
the other day we were making a joke
about doing a skit
so we were talking about the the kaiser
chiefs clean hands raise your hands
washing them and like how creepy it was
and i was like it would be a really
great skit if we
set up like this this little tent
and we had someone wearing what looks
like catholic garb but it's like pfizer
and modern on it right and people walk
up and they're like shaking and he takes
their hands and says with this washing
you are clean and then they put the
hands in the water and take the hands
out and then bring them into the hut for
their vaccination and so we make it look
like a religious ceremony and then
there's a joke about like fauci with
like with his hand up you know the peace
sign you need one or if you um you need
one where like if somebody comes up and
they and they have it he just like
smacks them really hard
i'm just going to smack the that devil
out of you yep
and then he does that being said go to
latin mass yeah that's right but so
that's the the the reference they were
making
tn hp podcast says the pfizer cult wash
your hands would only make sense at a
wiggles or teletubbies concert that's it
i mean not even you saw the video
the the the clean head right right we
all have clean hair i i've been like i
just i just i just love it wash it yeah
if you come out and was like yo
everybody wash your hands and then went
into rock and roll that would have been
cool but instead he called out pfizer he
was like yay pfizer corporation and i'm
like what the heck boom fifty thousand
checking in bank
wash your hands man thank you
just gotta he's got like the sticker on
his guitar and he pulls it up because he
goes to play guitar over the back of his
head and you see a big fighter logo on
there
hey the pills aren't just blue anymore
baby so here's the important thing you
all need to understand
when you have a decent amount of trump
supporters who will never disparage the
man who keep thinking every other day is
the day that trump somehow gets
reinstated and believe all these things
like i can understand why you criticize
that but these people are not have no
institutional power they tend to be like
older folks in the middle of nowhere who
aren't doing much they're not in media
when you have a major concert with
thousands of people all holding their
hands in the air and and testifying to
pfizer yo the cult is here that's the
problem i don't care about what
grandma's saying about her she's retired
i don't care what mimo is saying it's
about power dynamics about who has power
who's wielding power who when the
president of the united states is saying
that military members are going to be
giving dishonorable discharges which by
the way usually with what um
my contact is saying it does include
prison time right
that's power that's real power
and people in the west need to start
understanding this because anybody who's
lived through the east anyone who's gone
through the soviet union or through the
communist countries they've all seen
this before you don't need to talk to
somebody from poland or belarus or
ukraine or venezuela like you et cetera
et cetera you need to talk to the ask
them because they've seen this before
they've heard this work it's always for
safety it's always for the good of the
nation it's always for this is to make
you better it's for the good of the
public during the safety of the children
during occupy there was a cop who was a
little bit older and he said he was born
in the soviet union and his parents
brought him to america
and he was just he was talking to these
young people and he was like this is
exactly how it starts this is exactly
what i was warned about by my parents
and my grandparents and y'all are doing
it he's like an older guy and then he
was being argued with by like 20
somethings and they were like you know
you're talking about blah blah and i sat
there and then i was just like i don't
understand like he lived in the soviet
union
personally and his family fled when he
was a young child and they warned him
and she told him all these things
like you guys are just college hipsters
you have no idea what you're talking
about it wasn't even real communism
anyway man it's never been it's never
been tried really
well you know the thing is it's that
statement is right and wrong there's
never been a point where like everyone
got together and did communism because
the problem is there's always people who
dissent and then the communists have to
kill all of them yeah and then it just
falls apart nobody likes that i'll also
throw out there well you know man real
real capitalism has never been tried yet
so
yeah sorry libertarians sorry
i think but i i jokingly tweeted that
but i actually think it's still true
like it is
always some kind of regulation or
authority stopping people right all
right cornelius butt knuckle says ian
grain-fed beef doesn't mean it was fed
grains whole life it just eats it uh it
just eats
a diet of grains the slaughterhouse
before it's slaughtered think of it more
like grain finished oh i see
a lot of corn
it's really much more of a grating than
a killing floor timmy
it's more of a
bottomless pit into a grinder than a
floor don't be fooled given the chance a
cow would kill you and your entire
family is that what he says
ready to graduate from bovine university
michael brogan says i wanted super chat
on many topics tonight but they all been
covered on the subject of cancellation
jack elijah schaefer and sydney watson
beat you nine days and and uh you are
here has been banned from youtube two
strikes one vid two strikes on one vid
on one holy cow banned like permanent
band two strikes is what like three
months they were just talking they've
only been up they were just talking to
me about getting on that show
i was about to fly down to texas i guess
i guess
you get a phone call
i do all right we'll see you then click
hey jack we're cancelled so hey you were
canceled so uh so no show wow that's
crazy i was literally just talking about
it it's still up though so i don't think
it's banned no they get a strike and
they can't post anything they can't post
anything it's so it's like you're um
it's like being locked on twitter yeah
and then naughty naughty wow they didn't
do anything by the way speaking of
australia with sydney um i love that um
this idea that they're calling the
protesters in in australia the the
orange vests
so because a lot of the it's the
construction workers i think they they
say tradies is like is there a word so
it's a lot of construction workers a lot
of truck drivers and so you have the
yellow vest the g legend in france but
in australia it's the orange vest i love
that i love that name that's awesome all
right jp says tim the late rush limbaugh
has great patriotic kids book series
called the rush revere series
you know i i just for mentioning rush i
want to point out we watched the nutty
professor a couple days ago you guys
have seen the night professor sure
maddie murphy plays all the family the
clumps and
they want to be fat so he does a serum
that makes him skinny and then it's dr
jackman excellent cameo with dave
chappelle there was a yes dave chappelle
was it was hilarious women murphy women
yeah i know it's funny and that is true
women do shut up scene is great eddie
murphy screaming and laughing it's a
good scene but
when uh uh well there's two because he
goes back when he's right buddy love his
body love is the funny part when when uh
sherman the main character is at his
house eating a bowl of ice cream after
buddy love makes fun of him and he's
pouring reese's pieces and m m's in his
mouth
they show the tv and to the left of the
tv is a bunch of books and one of them
is a rush limbaugh book wow i never
noticed that i thought that was funny
because i saw that because i was like
man back in the day you could go live
pool over here you could i know who the
sniper is going to be yes 10 oh yeah i
can i just see everything but i thought
it was crazy because um
back in the day you can make a major
blockbuster and it was normal for
a college professor have a rush limbaugh
book
nowadays people would be like they're
they're dog whistling it's a it's a dog
whistle why are they you've actually
just just initiated the cancellation of
the nutty professor but eddie murphy's
done yeah so and eddie murphy they're
going to go in and they're going to
digitally remove the russian library oh
right they just remove it it'll be uh
ibram candy harry potter no it can't it
can't be a harry potter either yeah it's
going to be even candy even candy yeah
it's going to be um robin delaney
i've had it with the stupid cancel
culture
book burning thing man i just want to
get back to communication russia's books
are great by the way russia's books are
great um his are for a little bit older
i think they're more text um the ones
we're doing they have like they're a
little bit younger kids but russia's
books are fantastic and you know it's
really something where like you start
with the brave books when they're
younger you go to the rush books and
they're a little bit older they're
working on reading and it's it's i mean
you keep going with it just keep going
love peace and harmony says how long do
you think till the usa really starts
going heavily downhill uh have you
looked at the cost of food inflation gas
the southern border the afghan crisis
i mean should we really just start
listing do you understand what will
happen if the us dollar
is no longer the world reserve currency
imagine the deflationary
spiral that we'll be in and then imagine
what happens when there's no it would be
deflationary who have all their
worthless right be worthless be done so
imagine
imagine your
savings
are worth nothing if you have your money
in in cash which imagine a gallon of
milk for five thousand dollars right you
think i'm joking that's hyperinflation
that's what they were seeing in vinemar
germany right yeah so and then imagine
the social
consequences of that yeah um the best
part is america will be completely done
it'll become a wasteland for the most
part too many people uh all of our
people live
let me let me let me by the way none of
us want right
i want to simplify this very much like
kurt schlichter always says i don't want
these books to come true people in new
york don't do anything
they they may do administrative work
they may do blog writing they may do
managerial work they may do intellectual
work but they're not making food
when the u.s dollar is no longer the
reserve currency the u.s has no control
over oil and can't get any food stops
showing up and the people in new york
will start fleeing rapidly and those who
stay it'll go basically full on mad max
i mean crime will go through the roof
what people need to understand about the
petro dollar is that when the u.s wants
to buy oil it simply borrows or prints
money when other countries want to buy
oil they need to trade for us dollars
first and then buy oil that means they
need a robust gdp with good exports so
that they have they're continually
gaining value
they have to buy and trade
so you so you take account which means
there is always a market for dollars
right and so the u.s has one great
export
the dollar
and that's only because it was tim cast
irl right that's because the petro
dollar so that's why all of these people
who have come out against the u.s
dollars of reserve currency just like
mysteriously end up dying you know i
mean you know gaddafi wanted an african
union and he wanted to trade i think it
was in dinars and then he died still a
big question zane was challenging that
still a big question about where exactly
is all that gold from from the libyan
treasury oh yeah yeah yeah then again a
lot of libya is the sahara desert so you
got a bunch of gold you gotta hide
somewhere i'm just saying that's gonna
be hard to find but they're like
shifting sands but they are letting his
son out of prison last i saw so i think
the question is does he know where daddy
kept the gold we don't have a
manufacturing base anymore we import too
much if we lose the dollar i was smarter
by the way getting rid of that i was so
smart very strategic i think i think
good job ruling class right i think we'd
see what like population collapse by
like double digits within a few years
which by the way and i have to do this
um since i'm here um we lost a great one
this week not just north mcdonald but
also angelo coudeville
professor uh boston university also
claremont i had the honor of actually
being
having him as one of my professors when
i was going through the fellowship uh
and he wrote a book about the ruling
class from the right in 2010.
so understand how far ahead of people he
was what is his name angela cotavia so
he was italian moved to us when he was
young served in the us navy
and then went to the senate intel
committee and then eventually made his
way to claremont institute also taught
at boston university just just absolute
genius um couldn't stand the intel
community he said the heads of the heads
of most most he said if you look at
history and you realize that how many
heads of intelligence agencies have
turned out later to be traders you
almost have to wonder if it attracts a
certain type or at least offers them
that incentive
genius so we we do have some news on
elijah and sydney mike sullivan says
they are still doing the show on blaze
media which is exactly why you should
become a member at timcast.com perfect
now
you can go into the member section what
you need to understand is that our
timcast members only content is a
massive library of all of our guests so
we've got like a couple from colonel
allen west we've got a couple from steve
bannon i think we have a couple now from
no we only have one from alex jones
don't we yeah i think we only want the
one but uh we have a bunch of other
people so you can search the names and
see every time they've been on for our
members segment and you can watch all
that stuff so there's a great value
every day monday every monday through
thursday we're adding new members only
podcast they're typically around a half
an hour the alex jones episode is an
hour and a half long this latest because
like we we're going at it and you know
alex you know he takes over and then you
know you try to you can't stop it i
looked down at eight minutes and or at 8
50 while we were doing the show and i
was like i thought we were still doing
the intro it was 50 minutes in i was
like i feel like we're in the intro
still
alex is like the juggernaut next man
yeah once he gets going you can't stop
him and i'm like
alex and then he's like thomas jefferson
was in charge of the illuminati and i'm
like oh no
it's fun though so make sure
become a member at timcast.com we also
have a bunch of journalists we're hiring
more uh
we we have the paperwork for the new
fact checking foundation talking to some
people looking for some fact checkers so
a lot of a lot of big important work
happening we're gonna be we're looking
to expand our corporate headquarters and
we've been looking for new buildings
because we're looking to hire a lot of
people all of you who sign up to be
members are supporting our ability to
hire people to make more crazy stuff
it's awesome thank you all so much don't
forget to like this video subscribe to
this channel you can follow me at tim
cast basically everywhere and you can
follow the show at tim cast irl jack uh
yeah so it started up with the new
podcast human events daily it's now up
from turning point live so huge shout
out to the whole crew over there
you can go follow it it's sort of an
evening briefing it is 25 minutes it is
the cliff notes of war room the cliff
notes of your day it you we use an old
adage that i learned when i was in the
military especially in the intelligence
briefing be good be brief be gone this
is your bottom line up front you can
share it with your normie friends it's
something where i'm just giving you high
impact analysis the main stories of the
day you're in you're out you're done 25
minutes right on uh yo you guys thank
you for being a part of this thing man
we are really expanding this operation
we're set we're building out the
fetavers to build some decentralized uh
social networking
technology i mean i'm looking at really
starting a new revolution of industry as
making the united states the graphene
production center of the world i think
that's absolutely possible let's stress
that fetavers thing real quick too i
mean ian and the crew have been working
around the clock developing code and
getting this stuff ready to launch and
the key is decentralized open source
social media technology so that you can
host your own presence that interlinks
with other people's sites so you cannot
be banned or removed and you can have a
strong central location for your content
and a decentralized network
and then we say to all of these big
companies i want to ban and censor
people you can't stop the
decentralization but you can't join the
fetiverse
so thanks for coming and being a part of
this again i love you thank you
and you guys thank you very much for
helping me achieve my life goal of
beating sour patch kids and follower
count that's all i care about don't care
about the photoverse i'm just kidding i
care about all the other projects we're
doing but you got to maintain you got to
maintain now i'm working on it i'm
working on it i think i think you're
gaining distance already i know i'm
scared i'm scared anyway you guys may if
you so choose follow me at sourpatchlids
on twitter we will see all of you at
timcast.com in our members segment
thanks for hanging out
you